Oh welcome to fat man I'm Kevin and I am
mark barnard happy Star Wars everybody
it's fitting as per usual we're doing
the show live from the scum and villainy
Cantina here on Hollywood Boulevard and
beautiful Hollywood California put your
hands together so everyone at home knows
this is a real live audience collection
as let's see it's what Tuesday yeah so
we've been with the last Jedi since like
late Thursday night for some folks but
let's just say Friday so all Friday off
Saturday all Sunday Monday for days with
the force the movie did it's insanely
well all these Star Wars movies they
certainly don't need word-of-mouth
they're doing quite well and [ __ ] like
that but this one wasn't expected to go
as high as it was yeah as force awakens
like did they did about 10 percent less
like that's massive
it's two hundred and twenty million
dollars opening weekend domestic so it's
making all the money and right off the
bat it screams that like we all knew
this but Star Wars is as like American a
brand as [ __ ] coca-cola at this point
like it's just gonna be with us like
cancer forever
wet weather we wanted to not will never
be in a world without Star Wars so far
were one that though I did a long ass
review on of the movie on Facebook which
became a podcast version of fat man on
Batman but nobody's heard what you've
had to say about it you know I've been
really Cajun so I have to start there
low-key show maybe oh my god I'm just
like this I'm not
anyone foreplay I go right first off
here a little conversation how you been
I'm doing all right man all right now
did your reviews here man let me share
something with you on time ago chasing
amy was the movie that got me jumped
into the Academy the Academy of our own
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences the
fountain at me yes and so the idea of
being jumped into the Academy you know
means hey I'm part of this now and I'm
pursuing an Oscar that was never true
for me the whole [ __ ] thing I liked
was like I hear they give you free
[ __ ] movies and [ __ ] and they do
we're on an Oscar season BAM you get to
see every [ __ ] movie there is it's
tough all the movies that are up for
Oscars certainly there was no yoga hose
or screener last year I promise you so
this year man that's all right I'm good
this year this year I was delighted
because we're in an era of geekdom where
like my passions are now mainstream and
show like that you start to get genre
Oscar screeners yeah so last week or
this was this week in the last few days
thor ragnarok came as a DVD that I'm
like are you kidding me I could just
watch this anytime I want and so like
it's it's at your fingertips yeah it's
like having mouling here in your own
[ __ ] hands and [ __ ] he who is not
worthy so I had that and I was like it's
not gonna get better at this and my wife
was like well one thing sent Star Wars
oh I get out of your [ __ ] minds they
ain't gonna send stories it just came
out they're gonna wring every [ __ ]
penny out of that [ __ ] they're not gonna
risk putting an oscar script I got a
[ __ ] last Jedi Oscar screener at home
today man they [ __ ] sent it out I am
coming to your house it's crazy man I
did not expect that they would go fast
with it so I'm gonna be able to watch
that [ __ ] at home frame by frame that
[ __ ] and be like look at her fly
but I was shocked that they actually did
it but I guess they feel like look we
got a serious shot of the words why not
yeah I mean it'll get nominated for
every below-the-line thing like all of
the effects all the costumes all of that
[ __ ] but I think there's a world in
which Carrie Fisher gets a Supporting
Actress nomination that's what I thought
that's why it was smart to get it out
there it's like you could totally you
know like hey man this is the
performance that ends it so how about we
acknowledge an entire career right and
so they could at the very least get a
nomination for Supporting Actress yeah
like is this the best she's ever been no
but people want Oscars for not the best
they've ever been all the time
absolutely and I know she's like she's
there I know she's not in like a lion's
share of the movie she's in at a bunch
but people at one Oscars for less screen
time as well so there's a good chance
man that's that's actually yes besides
the technical [ __ ] which they'll sweep
they could definitely get the Karen eyes
I honestly think they could get a
screenplay nod because there's enough
like twists and turns in it and enough
recreations of the franchise and when
people talk about it they tend to talk
about the story good or bad and the idea
is there people are parsing it could
wind up getting a screenplay back and
you know they also extended or they
widened the category for Best Picture
used to be five and only five now they
opened it to ten sometimes 11 or 12 I've
seen as deep as simply because they want
movies and people have seen to get
nominated for Best Picture
now they're we're gonna win but they
want your okay avatar I guess sure you
should be nominated for something
because people have done so everyone
who's ever [ __ ] me said okay sure
let's do it you should get something I
would I'd be okay with that if I was the
okay sure you get nominated
my god I'm so much it's [ __ ] amazing
but I've never pursued that that's never
been part of my DNA excellence not for
me that's what I kind of I just want to
kind of get it done you know like I
think I've talked about this many times
as an indie filmmaker it was an ethos
that was built into me and I've seen
peers and people who came up after me
move beyond this sensibility so I'm not
saying like all indie filmmakers like
this case in point Rian Johnson isn't
any filmmaker wasn't any filmmaker and
now he's like you know [ __ ] it was
now he made [ __ ] less cheddar so you
could move beyond it stuff that being
said disclaimer aside my indie ethos is
is very simple in order to get something
completed like that's otherwise it's a
dream and you're like oh [ __ ] we didn't
finish you just got to finish the
[ __ ] thing so I I've never started a
career and I still don't and my career
strive for excellence because you lose a
lot of time doing that so in order to
[ __ ] just get something to put
together you have to be kind of the
person that's like that's good enough
and so I've been looks good enough my
whole [ __ ] career and [ __ ] that's why
they don't let me to your Star Wars I'm
like that's good enough they're like no
it's not try harder I'm like why yeah oh
my god leave it in black and white it's
good enough but yeah I think it it
they tried much harder I think they
there's a world where you can get a
screenplay not because they're doing
something kind of different and people
are talking about story you know what
I'm saying for the first time whether or
not you're like agree with the story
there are plot points in that movie and
new ideas that apparently challenge some
long-term fans of the franchise yes
apparently there's a petition or a
handful of petitions online one of which
I saw that now has 25,000 signatures to
remove last Jedi from the Canon
like this we should never acknowledge
this abomination of a film ever again
like [ __ ] that's it's the Christmas
special and this [ __ ] never mention that
[ __ ] again wait a second
he's 25,000 signatures aura that's a lot
of [ __ ] people but at the end of the
day let's do the math 25,000 people go
to see last Jedi pay 10 bucks apiece
let's say they go I went to an $18 20
bucks apiece
20 bucks New York they all went in New
York yes I can't do that man 10 bucks I
can do then that's 500,000 all right
500,000 half a million dollars yes
they'd be pissed kissing away that's
half a million dollars worth of box
office business how much did it do this
weekend two hundred and twenty million
dollars domestic of other 230 million
international I made 22 million
yesterday who's who owns Star Wars now
Disney Disney's like yeah you know what
freedom of speech sign a petition we're
all for it
we're gonna sell one more coke an hour
at Disney across the parks we'll be fine
yeah and also you people who are signing
it went to the movie that's it you'll be
back because of course you'll be back
when you got your money [ __ ]
mm-hmm
all right so people are pissed some
people some people a very vocal amount
of people I'm certainly not dismissing
him and stuff everyone's at owe to their
opinion I saw a big generational shift
between those that were okay with like
the fate of Luke Skywalker or and not
even the faith I don't even have to
spoil it and and by the way we're gonna
expect this [ __ ] to get spoiled hard if
you're like I've been seeing it yet
you're in the wrong [ __ ] bar I'll
tell you that right now
the LA you know some based I even on the
trailer but the idea of a Luke Skywalker
that has become a hermit and his like
[ __ ] the force and [ __ ] that seems to
have divided an audience where people
our age are just like yeah man
you get tired and you know people who
have forces hard people who still
believe you know or young Millennials
and [ __ ] like that they're like he's a
[ __ ] hero why would he quit this is
[ __ ] and I think there's a
generational split there I don't say
either side as right or [ __ ] wrong I
will say this though it's a movie and
not like it's a movie I suppose I mean
it's a movie in as much as he can't be
into it from the first day if she was
like you got to come back and help he's
like golly wilikers I've been waiting
for this like three the [ __ ] movie if
he goes back right away so he of course
you know she has to show it would be
like you got to come back and he's like
yeah I'm think so and hold out until the
end until [ __ ] until he still doesn't
come back but it's that had to happen I
was okay with that
mmm you know and and I like the whole
movie but what they eventually did with
them you know all things come to an end
I was okay with that as well but we'll
talk about we should let you [ __ ]
review the movie and I'll I'll talk
about my thing when we get to your thing
you can shine through your thing all
right so where did you see it set the
stage I saw it I've seen it twice now I
saw it once we could go yesterday at a
press screening on the Disney lot which
was actually kind of cool because I've
been to a [ __ ] ton of press screenings
in the twenty so many years I've been a
journalist and they invited 75% of any
given theatre they had a screening every
three hours in the Disney lot 75% were
critics and journalists and whatever and
25% were fans it was very like oh hey
there's a five-o first Legion all in
line to go in and you see them all
walking by us and in the screening
because I think they a wanted to sweeten
the room so because fans will love this
movie was there thought and and be just
to outreach you know the guys we are
embracing you we realized that there's
gonna be some [ __ ] in here you might not
dig but we are we're here for you come
and see it tell us what you think right
so was the first time I saw it on Monday
and I loved it like I walked at that
theater just like [ __ ] on cloud
bespin 9 whatever whatever cloud that is
and uh very mixed metaphor there Lando
thank you
I've been hitting the colt 45
and like loved it loved it loved it
loved it like I I grade Star Wars movies
at this point by how many moments feels
like Star Wars to me okay you know
because all of these movies all at this
point 8/9 of these movies have problems
all of them do story wise like there's I
love Empire Strikes Back but I've mapped
during big about like nine times it's
true it kind of drags a little bit you
know like swamp jumping can you watch it
dude do it turns out a lot because they
make you watch it's weird man like when
you saw that movie as a kid at least me
maybe because I was a fat kid I was like
man what rigorous training and like now
if they're like just if you do this
you'll be a [ __ ] Jetta I'd be like
I'll [ __ ] do that like all you gotta
do is go jogging with a puppet and stand
on your hands and [ __ ] like that
can you op down by the puppet firm how
much could you run on Dagobah it's not
even a mile loop I'm sure that's true
it's not cardio daga baz a whole planet
yeah but that's for the town that he
lives in I think it's a whole planet so
it's like New York New York dag about
Dagobah
he's like if you go [ __ ] a mile that
way man you're in [ __ ] dag Abood a
Gabon new daga but yeah it's like
[ __ ] posers over there new Dagobah
McMansions hipsters [ __ ] maleeni's
get a super nice [ __ ] Hut but like
all these movies even the prequels like
there are moments in each of those
movies that are phenomenal
yes surrounded by a bunch of nonsense
but for a moment you're like oh [ __ ]
duel of the fates this is great like you
could rock this movie could run so close
yeah like attack of the clones like most
of it is [ __ ] but then you get to this
amazing battle sequence on Geonosis when
it's a dust storm and all you see is
like red lasers and blue lasers and it's
super impressionistic and it's the fog
of war happening in front of you like
it's kind of great Revenge of the Sith
there's a big [ __ ] fight at the end
where people get their legs and arms cut
off like just parts of it that are super
[ __ ] metal and then he says no and
then we all just abandon it but they all
have these moments in the more moments
you get for me the better a Star Wars
movie it is yes a new hope has the most
moments for me they're our largest
moments of grandeur and magic and
specialness and uniqueness and
classicism and from all the places that
Lucas is drawing these the his sources
from and you get [ __ ] hands streaking
out of the Sun which is maybe the
greatest moving moment I've ever seen in
my life the Millennium Falcon yeah come
on kid let's blow this thing and go home
is all this moment this is this of
spine-tingling for me like if you could
juice that [ __ ] I would drink it every
day they they give you a piece of it in
this movie they give you comes to the
rescue again and you're like oh [ __ ] and
I don't I don't even mind the kind of
cyclical nature of these movies like it
is yes it's symphonic in a way and there
are themes and there are there are
musical cues that story cues that will
just come back and they will echo and
they will bubble up history doesn't
necessarily repeat itself but mostly it
rhymes right totally and so there are
four moments in this movie that are
among the best moments I've ever seen in
a Star Wars movie there's the opening
sequence the [ __ ] run on the on the
Dreadnought bomber I agree one of the
best battle sequences in space in terms
of a movie franchise called Star Wars it
was one of the best Wars and in the
stars they ever did and all the movies
the best of the wars yes all the mores
there is there is kylo Ren and Rey back
to back in the middle that Crimson
[ __ ] Chamber which is amazing I like
a lot of people liked it more than I did
I was just like I mean I like the idea
of them teaming up but I saw some people
right this is some of the greatest
[ __ ] lightsaber battling I've ever
seen in the mood
and I think it was just maybe because he
like let him do it in the
frame without cutting looks like they're
literally swinging swords around so
these kids knew what they were doing as
opposed to cutting now again it's going
so straight way down you live in my
Shack you Fox this is where I gotta
stand on a box
there's my hammock on but like that that
is the most you know [ __ ] back to
back amazing story reversal you don't
expect that to happen yeah when it
happens it lands like a [ __ ] Thunder
you get the the hyperspace jump which is
the most beautiful thing I've ever seen
in a Star Wars movie the Lightspeed yes
yes when when Admiral holder although I
miss ya just [ __ ] kicks it into gear
and slices and dices an entire and how
excited like at what point did you
figure it out the moment they cut
they're looking at the resistance ships
getting blown out of the sky yeah it's
like somebody's gonna do this thing it's
gonna funnel yeah and it was glorious
the moment she [ __ ] went for the
chair I was I saw in the theater where
my seat recline and so the whole movie I
kept going no yes
oh my god so that was a moment where I
leaned forward because I felt like no oh
my god if you do this this will not only
be one of the greatest moments in a Star
Wars movie but one of the greatest
moments to submit they [ __ ] did it
she went to Lightspeed and ripped
through Snoke sigh ass and they did it
in silence because in space no one can
hear you [ __ ] square they cross the
streams
it was [ __ ] glorious it's glorious
and it's the most anime thing I've ever
seen in Star Wars movies uh you're right
the - yeah that's true that's oh my god
there's a little bit of cure going on
there it's cool and and then Luke
standing on a what looks like a
blood-soaked plane facing down the first
order with a laser sword is an indelible
image
how the [ __ ] that wasn't the poster is
beyond me unless they were like I we
don't want to spoil it but [ __ ] spoil
that [ __ ] because they give it a minute
they spoiled it themselves more or less
but like if you had put that on the
poster the idea of [ __ ]
old man Luke they were behind him and it
kind of looked like Luke from Return of
the Jedi and you saw the entire first
order all those [ __ ] walkers and [ __ ]
and and and kylo ren's [ __ ] special
plane facing them down that summed up
the Luke Skywalker of my child and I
guess that was kind of the point right
here's the [ __ ] legend like this is
it look at him facing down like they
literally set up the joke in the
beginning of the movie where he's
looking like a face [ __ ] it face the
whole first door the goddamn laser sword
and then in third act you're like yes
the force is real but but there's
conflict on that because you know I
remember the first time I saw it in the
theater first because I saw it twice in
the same day my first screening I was so
enthralled by all of that that when they
you know gave it away like what here's
what's really going on I was like oh oh
[ __ ] that's a cool idea and stuff and
then you're moving forward and just
seeing the movie for the first time in
taking in new information so I didn't
bump into it ii bless you second
screening i that's why i was like i
bumped into it a little bit more well
i'm like why why couldn't he have just
been on crate why did he have to force
project himself like and I talked to
mark after I finally said Lew because I
knew he saw it before me and I was like
you're good writer can you give me a
good enough reason why I'm not saying
they have to do this but why couldn't he
have been there physically why did he
have to be a force projection no reason
mark didn't have a good reason I mean
the reason why I think they chose that
way is to honor the kind of tradition of
Jedi as trickster as prankster like
qui-gon was all about [ __ ] like
pulling [ __ ] heists and [ __ ] like no
this I'm gonna [ __ ] steal this pod and
now you're gonna release the boy to me
and his mother and look at me doing [ __ ]
that's kind of illegal but I don't care
because I'm a Jedi right you know Lester
it's a misdirect like oh [ __ ] this is
what's happening psych but if you're
gonna kill him anyway
what yeah all right hold on but you know
what also goes off Mike the thought was
he knew he was gonna die he wanted to
die in front of to suffer
so hold on did he pick do you think he
picked Ock too because it had two sons
and was that the only time they showed
the two sons as when he was dying
did I miss another moment where they
were like it look happens all the time
on this shitty planet it's it's not the
only time they showed two sons ah knock
- uh knock - there was another moment
where at one point there were two son I
believe so I'm not saying you're wrong
but I think like I would have picked
that up because there was a moment when
he was dying and I saw two sons and I
said oh I wonder if that's meant to be a
reflection or was it a planet with two
suns and did he choose a planet of two
suns and if he did holy [ __ ] that's
really moving not the only reason why
what's the other reason the Jedi Temple
entry is there why yeah
the Jedi literally started on the island
of octo the books moved with Yoda and
then moved back to the tree I mean all
of this [ __ ] is there because Rian
Johnson wanted it there and honestly if
Rian Johnson really wanted the twin sons
put those twin sons on Crete they could
have big [ __ ] why could not plan
enough twin sons why couldn't every
place Luke goes have two [ __ ] twin
sons that says GPS is twin sons ectomy
but where am I going
oh now what when I find it one son
[ __ ] he's like look I get my Jedi
power from twin sons what do you want of
a time I'm like super Superman somebody
because I put it up in the review I did
and Facebook that became the podcast
bless you I was like I said why couldn't
you've been there himself and somebody
hit me on Twitter I wish I could
remember their their name but their
breakdown was like really Star Wars
literate number one he said even if he
raised the ship cuz I said like come on
man you don't show a sunken x-wing in a
[ __ ] Star Wars movie unless sooner or
later some other [ __ ] gonna go that's
why you fail just like but they didn't
like I was a real MacGuffin and [ __ ] and
a real just like he got here that's how
he got here and that's it so the person
said on Twitter you can't make it jump -
they were he was far I really went lost
he went D
no way he could have got to crate
without a jump to Lightspeed hyper
hyperspace he's never they call it in
those movies and you can't do that
without an astromech droid so without an
r2d2 he couldn't have that's what I said
when I read the tweet I was like that's
[ __ ] true yes it is nerdy yeah but
you could you he couldn't do it if he
wanted to be there
this was their excuse for Luke there
Luke splainin to me but I'll take right
and yet
Andrew our friendly cameraman producer
was like well then how the [ __ ] did Luke
get there like he must have had an
astromech droid in that [ __ ] x-wing
at some point to get to the middle of
nowhere and then we got to the middle of
nowhere he was just like I'm sorry and
he kept that real Mexico oil spilled and
[ __ ] kicked him off the cliff like
these are all story problems you could
solve and then he won't the walrus but
yes so like the temple made Luke
stronger except he disconnected from the
force so it didn't matter it's like
sitting on a pile of steroids like
without the force now the temple just
makes me drier so yeah those those those
moments in it made me feel the way that
I felt when I was seven years old and I
first saw Star Wars yeah that's that's
what I go to these movies for nostalgia
for this jolt of oh [ __ ] wonder wonder
is childish joy but then like you start
thinking about the movie and you're like
alright the first act is pretty solid I
get it so distorted dread nod and
[ __ ] Luke is there and Ray's gotta
convince Luke he doesn't want to the
mission statement of the movie
ultimately is him tossing the lightsaber
over his shoulder the I don't need any
of this old [ __ ] like I don't
believe it I don't want it the movie
doesn't believe it doesn't want it and
wants to chart a new path I refer to
those as [ __ ] u JJ moments there's a bit
of that there seem to be a few of those
the first one is like the movie starts
with the bombing of the base that of
course away goes like we [ __ ] dented
so the opening of this movie base JJ or
whatever [ __ ] they're like blow - [ __ ]
off the planet
and it felt like a real [ __ ] you JJ and
then like kylo Ren gets bitched out by
Snoke and he's like you're a boy in a
mosque and then he's like [ __ ] this mask
and you know that mask was his whole
[ __ ] character last time and now
they're like we're getting rid of the
mask felt like another [ __ ] you JJ and
then there was another moment too I was
a good lord they seemed to be
dismantling everything that JJ's also oh
yeah we put so much story pressure on
Snoke and who was smoking what does he
mean
[ __ ] you JJ
not going to explain it not gonna give a
[ __ ] goodbye movies like who was he
they're like who gives a [ __ ] oh the
news cycle moved so fast and that Star
Wars movie it's crazy man suddenly he
was gone I did I was like I man this is
the movie where they might tell us it's
the [ __ ] Emperor he survived or it's
[ __ ] like I see people online thought
it might have been mace windu like I was
ready to hear whatever the [ __ ] he was
but they were like this is what he is
dead mother knew it yeah now the new
meat beat the new bad guys who are your
parents doesn't matter
nobodies what do you think of that do
you think that's accurate I mean I I
embraced the exact yard for now because
I think Rian Johnson's attacker for now
but I I sort of liked the idea of a Star
Wars protagonist that is not intimately
related to [ __ ] Luke Skywalker yeah
it is the most sort of inward focused
like everybody's a Skywalker or relate
it to a Skywalker who's that big bad his
nephew really come on
I'd like that moment where [ __ ] kylo
Ren was like that you're not even a part
of this story yeah like it's almost
stepping out of the [ __ ] character
out of the script you real meta moment
being like you have nothing to do with
the Skywalker lineage no one cares about
you or something like that that was dope
and then he was like what I do and that
was so seduction of the dark side it
wasn't just like you know that that's
the movies join me and we could rule the
galaxy together as father and son but
he's a lot less in your [ __ ] face
like I'm your dad
he's just like hey man [ __ ] I
understand he's this guy's like he's
making her at a bar just like now listen
you make it your term for this yeah
pretty much
negging it's the let me tell you why
you're not special oh but I find you
special that's a move that is a total
[ __ ] move I think the whole world's
been negging me forever
every critic my mother you're not worth
anything except to me hmm yeah
no you're not that pretty but you are to
me and that works apparently works for
kylo Ren work for color for a minute and
then she was like [ __ ] you I'm closing
the Falcon door and he was like was this
me and let me put a shirt on but like
house where did you ever think you see
so many pecs in a Star Wars movie no and
I continue to be troubled by how much I
have to hear the word master in a Star
Wars movie like master master master
oh but master my master my mess is like
come on I heard master more here than I
heard in roots somebody has a fetish I
would imagine it sounds the ultimate
worse if coming from charge yards it's
not good but the second act of this
movie has these weird [ __ ] problems
like I still don't understand a Finn
story at all I don't know why and why
what's wrong because it's alright so I
woke up and nobody knew that I was
missing really except for Poe because
we're lovers and so I wake up and I'm
naked and dripping sure and my first act
is to where's ray somewhere else I have
to leave because if she comes back she's
gonna die all right
where you going well it turns out that
we saw Battlestar Galactica and it turns
out that there's a ship that's that's
tracking the fleet and everytime we jump
they're just right behind us who said
that in my review that was they did an
episode like that right like is the
first episode of Battlestar Galactica is
that so it's like I remember there's
never said with had to jump every 20
every 33 minutes they got a jump that
was like the first after the pilot
movies that was the first episode so
that was familiar in order to make this
not happen me and this girl I just met
have to find a hacker to get onto an
imperial thing and I know where it is
because I'm in imperial I used to be a
stormtrooper kind of but I don't know
that part so I got to go find this other
dude on a casino planet and then we're
gonna go get caught because reasons and
everything that we've done will not
matter at all except we saved some sea
horses in space
sure all right questions yeah yeah why
couldn't those I mean there's a petty
gripe couldn't those horses have been
Tontons wouldn't that have been badass
if you were like oh [ __ ]
this is where they get Tontons from and
it ties in a little bit I know the whole
idea of this movie was [ __ ] whatever you
like about Star Wars but if it would
have been sweet if they were tauntaun
zone
I mean the only upshot of an entire
storyline is that Maz Kanata at some
point [ __ ] Justin Theroux
oh because she talks about she's like no
he's but I tell you the lava yeah she
says all right two mates thirty I've had
a good hands good at picking something
yeah all right sure I guess that was
Justin throws that was Justin the guy at
the table has no lines or we're like
what's happening now darling is about
all he says yeah yeah so there's massive
[ __ ] detour in the story that doesn't
get you anywhere
you then have Poe who has to somehow
like be angry at the women in charge for
like 45 minutes that's a way more
screentime in this movie yeah but
doesn't do anything and also like you
the things he does you like calm down
yeah dude it's fine
you're a soldier she's in command she
gave you an order to shut the [ __ ] up
and do what she says no mutiny all right
I know that was [ __ ] up man cuz when
they mutiny does like there's no way the
hero of this movie is going to have a
mutiny make mutiny against somebody like
who's really a hero
this clearly whole dough is gonna turn
out to be a villain and then she does it
it turns out to be a huge [ __ ] heroin
you know like oh my god Poe Dameron such
a dick yeah he really misread all of
this but why couldn't they have just
said calm down [ __ ] we're gonna load
everyone onto a [ __ ] escape pod ships
because they're tracking this [ __ ] not
those [ __ ] so that's the [ __ ] plan
right like there's there's no
established reason for secrecy yeah so
why not just tell them yeah especially
cuz he's such a pain in the dick just
[ __ ] do it alright here's what's
happening oh okay I get it fine and
suddenly they have cloaking devices in
Star Wars but whatever nevermind wait a
min the cloaking device because they
said no the ships are cloaked so the
the Empire won't notices and he slipped
a crate he closed well don't they have
they everything well how'd they get onto
the Death Star they're captured in Star
Wars right at the track Green pulls them
on you don't they own em then return the
Jedi don't they have to like [ __ ]
into a different code they trick them
right but nobody you can't trick them
anymore
not something I can't like Return of the
Jedi oh my god you know here's our code
now like that coach it's old but it
works and nowadays it's like we need
Benicio del Toro to get into this
[ __ ] bit right to do a thing to be as
Benicio was humanly possibly be they'd
be the guy you were in the usual
suspects he was like what the fan yeah
same for me yeah they've let Bella I I
just kept on wondering like if you have
to build this whole secrecy into it why
couldn't it be that the last time
anybody saw
Finn he was an ex stormtrooper who
somehow led to Han Solo died
hold on an area the last time we saw
Finn yes
reformed quote-unquote stormtrooper yes
who somehow led in some fashion to Han
Solo dying Ray's not there longer the
person who's really on that on the scene
Poe wasn't there the only person who can
say no he was a hero is Finn right okay
so suddenly the Empire is tracking them
they're not entirely sure how could it
be the [ __ ] stormtrooper that you
invited onto your ship did they ever say
how they were tracking well we got a
glowy lady box and that's how they're
doing but it's so wait you're suggesting
that she should have been fed it should
have been Finn he would have survived he
would have had a reason to a prove
himself to the rebellion by doing some
half-assed good I'm gonna launch myself
holder would have had a reason for not
trusting Finn big I mean not trusting
polkas he's in love with Finn so clearly
boyfriend and boyfriend they gotta be in
cahoots it ticks all the box it takes
all of the naked wet dripping boxes yeah
but no that's good writing I like your
version of the movie stop remaking the
last jet I just came out I'm sorry what
else you gotta have more than that and I
just a base layer spits I feel like
knowing full well that by the end of
production that they were not going to
have layer for the next movie yes there
were eight different places you could
have gracefully sent out Princess Leia
is the conversation we had on the phone
yeah would I I don't
isn't there a world where she's the one
on the ship who launches the [ __ ]
minute through Snoke ship like let her
blow out balls hard where it's just like
I spent my whole life trying to [ __ ]
fight these bastards I'm gonna give my
life this but I'm general Leia Organa
yeah and [ __ ] tear ass to the ship it
was you know I guess she's like hey my
friend died that sucks but you know it
would have been way better if it was her
and granted that's you have to figure
we're gonna lose her in Episode two
right but maybe I might have done you
might have you lose Han you lose Leia
and then you save Luke for the end of me
but like once you know that you're not
gonna have Leia for whatever Episode
nine is that's a fix you can make feels
like you could have built the sequence
and you could have put you could have
had Luke do his force communication with
Leia with her on the bridge of that ship
by herself right Luke could have visited
her just before she jumps like him had
the little moment Leia Luke here's some
dice like all of that [ __ ] as possible
you could have killed her when the
[ __ ] the the bridge gets smashed
alright I that was the first moment
where I kind of left forward in my seat
I could not believe it I was like this
is it this is how it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen this [ __ ] early holy
[ __ ] and then a few minutes later I was
like oh she's she's okay she's space
MARY POPPINS
I like the fact that she was
[Applause]
I'm Mara coffee job I like the fact that
she was alive and I like the fact that
she used the force I'm like come on man
this the first time we get to see Prince
lei use the force beyond like hearing
Luke or something like that in her head
so I thought that was cool but the
flying thing you know seems to be a
little much for some kid no much yeah
and the one the one of the thing that I
really wanted was I wanted to live in
kylos reversal a little bit longer
explain like I wanted I wanted the
victory I want to raise victory to land
on her and live with her long like I
[ __ ] did it
I turned kylo Ren I brought him back to
the light right and together we're gonna
get off this [ __ ] ship together hey
we might get off the ship and run into
Finn who's on the same [ __ ] ship and
we're never gonna meet but whatever like
that's right there we're all on the same
they're all the same [ __ ] so it's it's
let her live in that moment of
possibility and then just before she's
about to leave he extends his hand and
it's like no stay with me and let's do
this thing
I thought it was kind of dope though
where she was like oh my god you could
stop the ships that you know started to
stop the first order from blasting the
resistance ships and you know he starts
in with like let's think about this
little [ __ ] burn her her [ __ ] reaction
was really good was she's like open
please don't she like she look legit
scared like oh my god I had you don't
you don't like this is the worst [ __ ]
thing in the world you could say and
then he goes even further where he's
just like let's kill them all if I can
rule the galaxy together do you think
there's ever a moment when they were
right in the movie like [ __ ] it it'll be
great and met people wonder what [ __ ]
episode knows about it was it was
definitely one of the brightest times I
had in a movie theater this year like
just pure joy in the first screening I
I've my highlights have everything to do
with characters meeting old characters
old characters getting together so my
three favorite scenes I think in the
entire movie involve Mark Hamill it's
Luke you know seeing Leia of course Luke
seeing Yoda
of course it didn't I honestly didn't
expect that should have seen it coming
but didn't see it was delighted when I
happened
but hands down my favorite scene was
Luke seeing r2d2 that's when they
[ __ ] grabbed me by the heart it was I
had no idea because I'm like like you
know after the force awakens you're like
oh yeah I forgot the droids nobody likes
anymore you know we have a bb-8 now [ __ ]
the old droids and you forget that like
r2d2 when you were kid was your heart
you didn't [ __ ] talk you just beep
that you injured like that and he's so
integral to the story without r2d2
without Luke Skywalker meeting r2d2
without it [ __ ] that without r2d2
getting into an escape pod landing and
happenstance and Tatooine getting picked
up by the job wasn't [ __ ] to the point
where [ __ ] farm boy Luke Skywalker is
like I don't know we can get this one
and they get r5 d4 and he busts and
they're like let's take the [ __ ]
little blue one that changes the farm
boy's life we all that kid goes on an
adventure and we've gone on it with them
for 40 [ __ ] years because those two
characters came together and we're
besties and [ __ ] and you know there was
a moment force awakens whether they like
hey who's got the [ __ ] map and like
Oh r2d2 he's Lee was Luke's friend
wasn't being [ __ ] but when they put them
together in this in on the Falcon like
we'd seen the scene of him being in the
cockpit and you're like holy [ __ ] that's
gonna be amazing but when he did that
and what follows is him sitting now with
r2d2 BAM right away I was bawling in my
seat and then they pull the coup de Gras
where he's just like nothing in the
world and again you think yourself a fan
you think yourself a writer and you're
like how did I not see this [ __ ]
coming where he's just like nothing in
the world is ever gonna make me you know
[ __ ] change my mind and r2d2 turns on
the projection of Princess Leia I'm
[ __ ] it makes me choked up thinking
about it it's so beautiful that's what
sent this boy 40 years ago this old
grizzled man who's like [ __ ] the force
on the adventure 40 years ago was that
[ __ ] video and he's a different
person all together when he saw the
video he was like oh my god the rebels
and she's pretty and [ __ ] it wouldn't be
great if we dated
and so now he's looking at it 40 years
later through the lifetime that he's had
which wasn't just oh [ __ ] I was the hero
of the first three really great Star
Wars movies he's also like I'm the
[ __ ] Jedi that let down the Jedi
because I thought about killing kylo Ren
and he caught me and then if I can kill
everyone else and then I went into exile
[ __ ] like that I've lived so many
[ __ ] lives since I've seen this video
and now when I look at it there's my
sister like I have other memories that
we didn't get to see because they didn't
show every [ __ ] piece of their lives
together from between merch other than
Jedi forward and [ __ ] so there's still
stories that could be told but like in
our mythos that there's the glue that's
the reason the guy got on the planet
that [ __ ] droid that message changes
his all our [ __ ] lives so that seemed
for me was like Christ man like well
done applauding wiping snot off my face
what was your highlight I think it was
it was kylo Ren back to back with Rey
yeah it was it was I I did the thing I
did the thing that that few other Jedi
have managed to do which is pull
somebody back from the brink like
obi-wan couldn't really do it Luke kind
of did it but too late like I'm doing it
when this guy's at his prime before he
does all the damage you can do I [ __ ]
did it kinda not really yeah you know
and and I can't even I love the moment
that I went general Hux almost shoots
kylo when he's down he's just like
[ __ ] kill the [ __ ] out of this guy
anyways like oh hey what's up I just
wish that Huck's wasn't such a [ __ ]
idiot like how much more interesting
would that dynamic the kylo ren general
Hux denim have been okay if Hux was a
professional if Hux was like i went to
the [ __ ] academy I know what I'm doing
I'm like I'm like Norman Schwarzkopf I'm
a leader of men I can make your oh your
army run on time like I'm like grand
moff tarkin like what did we do
we built the [ __ ] Empire why cuz we
got the trains moving on time we got
troop movement supply lines like I'm a
professional [ __ ] soldier went into
the hip with this [ __ ] wahoo who
keeps doing dumb [ __ ] and smashing up
rooms and destroying elevators and
jeopardizing all of my [ __ ] plans
anywhere's imam mosque he looks like an
uncircumcised penis yeah he did that's
kind of just the tension between the two
of them like I don't need two guys being
totally [ __ ] crazy I need one dude
being like come on [ __ ] would
you just calm down let me do this thing
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna jump
one of our star destroyers ahead of this
flip is doing like 60 miles an hour like
OJ in the OJ [ __ ] chase and they will
run right into us we don't even have to
do anything this let's stand behind them
it'll be fine
nah man Pinsir [ __ ] just flank him
you know strategy no just gonna follow
them until I run out of gas what is that
[ __ ] yeah we have all this [ __ ]
weaponry at our [ __ ] disposal but
they'll stop sooner or later the god
right and then we'll have them sure yeah
I just wish there was more and that's
that's a JJ thing that's a I wanted him
frothing at the mouth like a crazed Nazi
general well but still Ryan
could have broken that mold of me I know
I know he chose to leave that for JJ
where maybe the dude who plays him dumb
ugly Donald Gleason yeah maybe he's like
I ain't doing this unless I get to play
it over the top at all times like all
right fair enough but I mean listen I
enjoyed my time at that movie it's
gotten vast problems and deep problems
from a story perspective but it did for
me what I need a Star Wars movie to do
for me you know when we defined itself
as it when it gave me moments that made
me feel like I was nine and what more
can you ask for in a movie theater than
just to have something happened that you
say Wow out loud
and if I give a definite let view a lot
of wild moments in the movie The Rose
summation of Star Wars I thought was
really [ __ ] beautiful
and I don't know if it comes from like
some real-world sentiment and stuff but
I thought it was incredibly well phrased
which was something to the effect after
she saves Finn he's like you know why'd
you stop me and she's like I saved you
yeah and then we won't win by fighting
what we hate but by saving what we love
oh my god which is a door [ __ ] except
you also win by fighting what you hate
don't be real man I mean they blew up
like nine death stars by now
what they ate it and when they won they
won they're like we're gonna do this
with love yes we killed [ __ ] three
for Death Star's in a row and everybody
working on him millions of Imperial
soldiers that we hated but we didn't
save but now that we have nobody left
we'd like what do you teach the world
yeah man it was it was quite the
experience you go with family that kids
I took my kid that's my kid opening
night and it's his favorite Star Wars
movie ever really yeah it's like this is
my favorite one and that's what it's for
it's these movies are not for me anymore
as much as I would like to think they're
for me they're for him
they're for the 12 year old 13 year old
kid whose parents dragged from the sea a
[ __ ] movie and it inspires them and
enthuses them and makes them want to
play in this world anymore
they got me turns to his parents like
let the past don't kill it if you must
so just don't walk so fast in the car
right I'm dying already
the what do we got after we good I got
to be able to talk about more Star Wars
than that I feel like no you emptied
your tank I did 90 [ __ ] minutes
what'd you do 10 I did 20 dude well then
20 minutes and good smart minutes to
most of mine were stoner man it's like
Oh long silence and in long silence but
yeah we are not going anywhere with
these Star Wars movies we're gonna keep
having them
I mean speculations I'm really curious
to know what JJ does with this next one
given that Ryan just tired of sucking
hands yeah you saw a fillet a problem
buddy
good luck making a movie where she's
alive but isn't there do you think
there'll be a lot of [ __ ] you Ryan
moments the first scene is kylo Ren go
and I do like this mask this is great
smoke is a force ghost dummy things you
know smoke comes together again he's
like him mace windu and Luke being like
I'm back Luke ain't going anywhere I
mean he sees one with the force and [ __ ]
like that
but he'll be a force ghost so and he
also literally tells us in the movies
like see around kid
there's no way on earth that that was
like I just thought I'd ad-lib that at
the end
clearly it's a nod to the fact that they
will meet again and that's gonna be
[ __ ] dope and [ __ ] we'll kylo Ren
awkward again looks like I came back
from the grave to fight you and he's
just like here's my second chance he's
like oh you're a [ __ ] ghost again
basically Luke Skywalker's Lucy Van Pelt
he just keeps showing up and pulling the
football away from the ground damn
yeah Chuck it'll be fine I let's talk
about all the money's that it made
domestically they expected it to open at
like 200 to 210 and they all sort of
junk it overperformed 220 was opening
weekend it added another 22 million
yesterday was the pack theater that you
saw him um yeah I mean I went to the
Chinese I went on opening night baby
at the Chinese our old stomping grounds
yeah that's truly did a show there yeah
wow what a magical place to see it
really was first time I saw it was in a
theater in Durango Colorado we were on
tour in Durango and so it was a tiny
theater they've got like a multiplex
there but they had a little to screener
called The Gaslight theater which was
built before I was even born like in the
[ __ ] 20 do you like everything that
it's at The Gaslight theater does a
Gaslight you into liking I mean it does
I was like this is amazing when I get
outside I'm like wait a sec hold on it
was beautiful if you had to see a Star
Wars movie as a adult version of a child
who saw Star Wars movie in the theaters
when he was 7 that's when I saw Star
Wars age 7 it looked like the theater
that I had seen Star Wars and it was an
old - screener and hazlit and stuff they
had better seats but other than that the
side deck the wall decoration was like
that curtain hang on the walls and [ __ ]
everything just wreaked of the kind of
seventies I think that added to
I think if I'd seen at a multiplex that
extra glaze of like it's the seventies
again wouldn't be there and felt like
that most of the movie I was like I feel
like it's the [ __ ] seventies and get
wait they killed my seventies icon D but
I'm used to that they did it in force
awakens as well but kill all you heroes
yeah see it is not gonna slow down
anytime soon is gonna top out at like
1.8 1.9 billion dollars which will be
less than Force awakens but they
expected that yeah but they didn't
expect it to be as strong as it's
currently is yeah they were expecting
like I knew 80% of force awakens opening
but you know does it keep going does it
all that I think so I mean like is
anything coming there's a bunch of
Oscars [ __ ] coming and Jumanji is on
Wednesday but I don't know how much that
takes a bite out of it right so it's
gonna roll through like February doing
good business excellent good for them
yeah man it's they certainly seem to
know what they're doing at this point
like even when they're like oh [ __ ] we
made a movie that people might not like
they like let's bring another director
and we'll [ __ ] finish it this way and
we'll put in like the greatest minute in
the Star Wars movie ever and we'll call
it rogue [ __ ] one it seems like even
when they're you know not swinging for
the fences we [ __ ] love these stories
so much audience gonna show up in droves
it's our mythology ottoman saw these in
marvel movies man you can invest in
you're always gonna make your money back
even if they kill our heroes yeah which
sounds like it's coming up for us in
maybe the last Jedi it's a kind of
appetizer for what comes for in in the
vengers infinity war because we know
we're gonna lose bunch of people a bunch
of main characters and those stories
yeah which will you be sadder at the
deaths in last Jedi or the deaths in
Avengers infinity war I mean they've run
out of people that I really care about
in Star Wars to a certain degree Louie I
know the droids so like in this [ __ ]
in this movie we kill we finally kill
the [ __ ] droids
that's what it'll be from now on it's
like oh it's Death Watch let's see which
one of our bonus beloved character
kill next the Star Wars movies become
like the couch on the talking dead
whoever [ __ ] sits there dies in the
[ __ ] show
yeah they got Chewie still tethers us
and Chewie could be Chewie forever right
yeah like they could replace Chewie is
like over and over
c-3po technically you can't ever replace
Anthony Daniels but a guy totally well
they've already replaced Kenny Baker so
r2d2 will be with us always I mean they
can still bring back Lando there I heard
a rumor that that part of the impetus
for the whole Kanto bike Casino sequence
know was that Lando was supposed to be
running that casino
what a [ __ ] what that's the reason to
go to that planet has another planet and
they looked like bespin guards yeah and
perhaps from what I understand there was
and again rumor from the internet so
take it as you will but that that Billy
Dee Williams isn't quite as suave as it
used to be and couldn't quite gin up the
necessary Moxie to channel Lando as well
as they wanted him to
and so they jettison that idea really
yeah you see bad because that would have
again been like a reason for that
even if they cut to him in the casino
even if he was the guys like there's
someone with a bloom on his lapel and it
was [ __ ] Lando at a table and she and
then still it winds up being Benicio the
tour at least you're like Holly [ __ ]
Lando
you know there was just a poster of
Lando in the wall just smiling at you
let goes Lando's blaze what is he doing
space [ __ ] I guess I guess the idea
though is I put in the movie together
like what will everyone want
what does everyone expect let's [ __ ]
go the other way like that's what it did
it was a movie that kind of any
expectation you had as we all sat there
gone oh Ray's got to be a Skywalker
she's got to be a Kenobi or she's gotta
be related somebody in the [ __ ] they
like [ __ ] you no not at all so it defied
a lot of expectations and you know
that's as storytellers I salute them as
Brian and he wrote it with somebody else
no he wrote all themself he's the first
person since George Lucas is that right
to get a solo written and directed by
credit on a Star Wars movie really yeah
I thought he had a guy that he always
wrote he produced it with a guy
yeah he's not a cobra I was not a
co-writer [ __ ] right on Wow good
friend so every one of the ideas there
is where did you wind up on porks at the
end of the day were you assimilated I
was not quite assimilated I I love the
fact that Ryan clearly hates [ __ ]
porks because Chuy was [ __ ] killing
him like he didn't eat them he killed
one too and to be fair he might have
found a dead one you know that maybe
they were like we can't put that scene
in the movie like he's just eating
carcasses off the ground I mean the
movies fine with dead ports just doesn't
want you to eat porks right and I I
align with the movie that way just don't
eat him but you can kill him all your
[ __ ] one I thought I thought they
were a nice color like seeing them in
advance in the movie or like holy [ __ ]
here come the new we walk but they were
just kind of nice background in a lot of
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] moment with Chuy
was like legit funny yeah legit weird
because you're like later on he's
pounding around with a port was that the
sad little board and did that port
become his friend because Chuy was like
I'm sorry I ate your friend now we can
be friends I beat you or you or was it
his mother and it was just like well I
guess I'm your mother now I think
there's a lot more movie they could have
got - I like the the fish nuns on that
planet more than I like the pawns who
would just like [ __ ] another Jedi
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up again another hole in
the wall another dead statue thanks Jedi
yeah they had names or whatever they're
the caretakers I guess I mean I didn't
even know the name of the island until I
saw it on high because nobody says it
right it's just all that Skywalker
Island Skyland for sure mmm yeah I was
branding it they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
I was calling a strong Island so why
does that come from the East Coast and
but never mind
my New York roots it seemed to be a
strong pro-animal vegan message running
throughout the movie or more pro-animal
than vegan like the idea like release
the [ __ ] horses and the [ __ ]
silver foxes they'll get us out of the
cave and you know Tony the [ __ ] poor
you piece of [ __ ]
they say Ryan must be a big animal lover
man my kid came out of the movie crying
she was like I loved it so much like
she's a real hardcore animal lover and
[ __ ] so the scene with Chuy
and the pork played completely
differently for her she was like
everyone was laughing and I was crying
hey pork was dead and then I was like I
know and then he didn't even get to eat
it so what a waste you know we eat what
we kill in this house
we got we got top tens in the year my
friend did you do your top ten no you
didn't do your top ten not yeah no you
got a tough time I got a top ten I could
comment on your top ten okay but only
color commentary in my top ten okay
I got I got a top ten I got honorary
mentions Wow yeah all this I got a full
[ __ ] list man I've seen all I'm gonna
see did you see the post no were you
ever gonna see the post yeah I mean it's
a Spielberg movie I see you all of those
I gotta be honest with you man I think
Spielberg did so I saw it I think he did
something really smooth I know he's been
in historical period lately and thank
God ready player one looks like him gone
let me show you how to swing a big fat
dick again I built this city on rock and
roll winner so it looks I'm glad he's
enjoyed himself making the historical
dramas that he's made bacon and [ __ ]
this is yet another one of those but
this one I really [ __ ] enjoyed it's
about the Pentagon Papers and so it's
about the Washington Post since before
the Washington Post was the Washington
Post we know from all the president's
men and history and blah blah blah so
the whole movies about the small-town
paper that's like constantly like what
does the New York Times doing and [ __ ]
like that
and they get a chance to break one of
the biggest [ __ ] stories of all time
the the Pentagon Papers was his name yes
but what was the guy who got him out
there god damn it I just watched the
movie and he was from real life to the
guy who copied the papers [ __ ] his name
kake's me maury povich yes it was maury
povich okay we'll take it he's a
character in it as well but the idea is
the Washington Post gets these papers
and they're like you can't publish him
because in Bradley shut down Ben Bradley
he's played by Tom Hanks and stuff Bob
and Dave from mr. Show are both in it as
newspaper men together it should I mean
it's one thing you're like of course
like you know Odenkirk is in what is the
show better call Saul
which is like on everybody's mind but I
was delighted to see David cross and if
I conceived it Spielberg movie I was
like holy [ __ ] this is fun Meryl
Streep's wonderful we've got every white
guy you can find except me I'm not in it
and so are you sure I've looked for
myself it's enjoyable from top to bottom
it's historical so I can't spoil
anything obviously you should know your
history and show one the movies over the
washing at the Y you know there's a
blind to the effect of like well that's
the weirdest [ __ ] thing that'll ever
happen at the Washington Post and then
they cut to the security or the cop
security guard at the hotel at the
Watergate Hotel like checking the door
and there's tape over it and then he
opens the door and they cut to the
outside of the Watergate and you see the
guy in the room with his flashlight you
know about to head into Democratic
National Headquarters and all the
flashlights of the dudes that are
raiding Democratic National Headquarters
and then credits so if you end that
movie and start all the President's Men
it's the exact same [ __ ] starting
point that had to be done on purpose
like a fan had to make that decision you
could have ended the Pentagon Papers
movie that is the post with like we did
it you know [ __ ] the we published
credit but he went one extra little
stinger just to get you that much closer
to the opening of all the president's
men that had to be in tension so the
post is the rogue one of hold history
yeah so much does like more of this it
was delightful so yeah there's a bunch
of stuff all doff on my list until the
first of the year when John were heavy
there's a couple that I still haven't
seen yet
like I haven't seen the post yet I
haven't seen all the money in the world
the Jay paul Getty thing that apparently
they put Christopher Plummer in in like
a week and a half to drop and he got a
[ __ ] nomination - yeah they say barely
is real good but again it's Christopher
Plummer who's always really good so
surprise
all right so you ready I am [ __ ] ready
all right I'll go honorable mentions
first okay Dunkirk
did you see the Dunkirk I have not you
might convince me to see it go ahead it
is it is it is a horror movie at its
core and that it's it's about the
unpredictable unknowable death that is
going to befall all of these British
soldiers as they wait for their pick up
to go home from the the beaches of
France I believe on their way back to
the UK okay no sanity yeah I'm like
sorry person's Dogma here's my list but
yeah like it's it's beautifully done
it's a little harmony sealed because
Christopher Nolan is an amazing
technician not so much with the human
emotions like Chris have you ever heard
a real person talk is fine go and you'll
appreciate this because Tom Hardy's in
this movie is II don't make me watch a
fight as a fighter pilot who for the
entire movie has his rebreather mask on
oh my god it's Bane to it it's prequel
Dana spree Bane pilot bank will pay I
still believe in things
rescued his men from the beach the
soldier
so yeah the Dunkirk so that's first
honorable mention first of all mentioned
baby driver okay if you're right
somebody Edgar Wright's movie which I I
have some problems with the
characterization of the lead and the
women in the movie are incredibly
shallow and Kevin Spacey is Kevin Spacey
but whenever Ansel Elgort this sort of
walking sponge of light in space
gets behind the wheel of a car it's like
a musical it's like a dance
I mean he's doing things with motion and
sound and choreography that I've never
seen done in a in a car-chase movie
before it's kind of beautiful and
definitely worth watching and the
music's amazing right on music is
amazing there's pretty much a genius
yeah but if you're not a car person
though um like I never seen one of them
fast and furious movies cuz I'm like I
give a [ __ ] about cars I mean it seems
like they're all about the cars or I
think I think if you're a person who
appreciates say the road warrior or
Ronin or any one of these sort of
classic car chase movies you'll kind of
get off on this a little bit if not it's
just a really interesting technical
exercise fair enough
the girl with all the gifts what movies
that it's a somebody liked it so much
that's a glass Mazel Tov one for the tip
it is a British zombie movie starring
Glenn Close which follows this little
girl one of a dozen children or so who
seemed to been infected with whatever
they're passing for zombie virus who
have managed to retain their
intelligence and master once managed to
retain their agency and their
intelligence and there's an entire
biological imperative to synthesize a
cure from these children but it's
following the life of one of these kids
and what it's like to be immune to a
thing that everybody wants you for even
though you'll die in the process even
though it's a horrible world you're
trying to save but what it feels like
it's a bit of a Stockholm Syndrome but
it's a really small
zombie movie from the perspective of
somebody super young who's also not
entirely unblameable British movie Glenn
Close yes so she's doing an actor she's
doing an accent you buying it close it's
like a poor woman's Meryl Streep put
that on the [ __ ] poster no like I
swear it was a rave by the guy he loved
all right fair enough maybe made me
curious about yeah what does it call the
like the girl with all the gifts girl
with all the gifts okay I am NOT your
Negro is a documentary that came out
earlier this year based on the sort of
lost writings of James Baldwin hmm a
sort of very influential like black
intellectual of the 40s 50s and 60s but
they they took a bunch of his writings
and they stitched it together into this
movie merited by Sam Jackson that is
both awfully precinct about race
relations in America and how it
implicates the government and society
and it talks about things that could not
have been relevant in the 60s but are
now like oh [ __ ] Ferguson he's talking
about Ferguson he's talking about
Trayvon Martin he's talking about this
sort of devaluation of black life the
the the sort of subjugation of will that
happens he's got this great quote
talking about somebody asked him are you
angry are you angry at white America and
his quote is to be alive and conscious
as a black man in America is to be in a
state of rage all the time and when you
look at some of the things that have
been happening the last five or ten
years you begin to take on a new
perspective to that thing I love
everybody in this room so you know but
yeah it's it's it's really heavy stuff
my last honorable mention we just spent
like 45 minutes talking about Star Wars
the last Jedi makes it on the list
make something list did not make my top
10 but makes on the list all right
they'll have to [ __ ] content
themselves with all that [ __ ] money
Oh No like we miss Bernardin's top 10
[ __ ] should we extend minutes ago we're
good yeah awesome
alright so that's your honorable mention
how much is number 10 war for the Planet
of the Apes ok I have I've still not
seen you still not see me it's a Andy
Serkis and Matt Reeves together have
created such a compelling character and
Caesar and they do I mean it's it's it's
an exodus movie in the same way that
another film in my top ten is it is not
quite as good as the other film on my
top ten that's an exodus movie um we'll
get to it a little bit later but it is
it is so incredibly deft with with
telling the story of Caesar and his
rebellion and his desire to save the
people slash primates that he loves the
most and it's a war movie it's uh
unabashedly a war movie it's a prisoner
of war movie and it's about the cost of
violence and what that price that the
toll that price weighs on both Caesar
and the people around him I liked the
first one
mm-hmm and then the second one were
they're like we ought to turn it on in
the damn a damn movie that that damn
movie that was where I was like this
feels long and so I never wound up
saying the war but now it sounds like I
love the damn movie today yeah a lot of
people love that damn movie I thought
it's fine but I'm like really the damn
that's the whole [ __ ] plot
I didn't realize last jeddah I was gonna
be really a slow chase through space
[Laughter]
yeah on iTunes I see it all the time and
I'm like well I know maybe it's got
another damn in it
damn free no there's a damn that's
important there like water and cool I
guess it's the electricity or whatever
oh this one's less that but there's
still a damn it's their Death Star
it's gotta be another [ __ ] dance like
we're doing one of these planets movies
gotta have a [ __ ] dam in it
all the new ones gonna pair care about
me apocalypse alright where do you go
next number nine guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 yes [ __ ] wonderful movie
wonderful movies that Crowley goes
higher on my list I think it for me it
was a little bit more of like hey I
really love this band I don't care if
they're kind of playing a cover you know
like I love everybody who's in it
I love the actors I love the director I
love the the the attack on a material
I just knew where it was going like you
knew going into that movie it's like oh
hey it's ego he's the bad guy
oh yeah he's his father okay now you see
what's gonna happen here he's gonna have
to choose between the father and his
friends alright yes the old family
versus the new family the one I chose
there's the one was born into I get it
it's all done well but I get it right
you learn no surprises there not as yet
all right so last Jedi threw you a
couple curveballs why does this go
higher than last Jedi and why is this
big the top 10 and Jedi's down over
mention because they think that that the
storytelling throughout this is is a
little bit more rattle tested there's
less weight like wow right let's head
scratching for me in guardians versus
last Jedi well defended alright where to
next number eight
spider-man homecoming oh that would make
my list too good no good [ __ ] poll
you know I mean it's a little bit sad
that the only way for us to get a John
Hughes style movie today is that it has
to be 180 million dollar superhero movie
right but it still was a John Hughes
style movie that I kind of love you know
movie about kids that felt like it was
starring kids that understood kids you
know and also understood what spider-man
is about and did not have to give us
another [ __ ] origin story done you
know origin stories yeah you know like
if you don't know who spider-man is by
now we don't need you that's cool
you've not been paying attention if
you're in a movie theater door what
comes with great maybe you haven't seen
one of these pictures before totally
like and if let's let's pretend you're
taking a kid who's never seen a
spider-man movie before it's not the
hardest [ __ ] origin to explain he got
bit by a spider gives him powers there
is a moment man I think it was in
spider-man homecoming I don't think yeah
I don't think they did it in Civil War
it was in spider-man homecoming I think
with Ned where he was explaining like I
can't do that to me you know what she's
been through
and you know I saw the theater I was
like I know [ __ ] show us that Christ
but think about it who's our Uncle Ben
and what happened same [ __ ] story
mm-hmm like is it the idea like in Civil
War when he's like when you could do
what I do and the bad things happen it's
kind of your fault
like he's literally saying the thing we
all know which is like I don't know if
you read the comics who saw the other
movies but like I could have stopped the
guy and I didn't then [ __ ] Uncle Ben
dies all over again
over also those wrestling involved
because there's always wrestling it's
true
somebody said something about wrestling
in the movie [ __ ] Michael Keaton goes
like the Shocker what are you a wrestler
yeah that's right they're obsessed with
wrestling yeah Stanley with some sense
of the wrestling really yeah what he did
there was the imagine this remember when
he went to DC and remade all of the
characters his version of Batman was a
black wrestler was it called the
wrestler I think it was called the
Batman and that's like dude not
everybody finds their wealth and
wrestling dude just simmer down the
world is moved on
kids like wrestling don't think God's
healthier from the top rope age match no
Stan all right where to next number
seven of the glorious Stanley hmm I
believe it's his 95th birthday coming up
holy [ __ ] yeah
[Applause]
unbelievable still kicking with us
goddamn legend loving yeah anyway uh
number seven thor ragnarok yes [ __ ] it
makes my list too yeah yeah hands-down
one of the also one of the best times I
had in a movie theater this year
just enjoy like there's not a lot of
bottom to that movie no but I don't need
a lot of bottom to that movie light as a
feather but doesn't matter cuz it's it
goes inside of a cushy down pillow that
you can go to the metaphor fell apart
but it's it's yeah it's not there's not
it's not deep but it doesn't need to be
it's not asking for depth and every
third [ __ ] scene in that movie should
be the side of a van so it is glorious
to look at visually [ __ ] stunning but
also just goddamn fun it puts like fun
into a comic book movie a lot of comic
book movies of course tend to be a bit
more ponderous this one just embraced
yeah its kooky premise and [ __ ] like
one for it and in doing so delivered a
better version of that movie than we've
ever seen previously I like your first
Thor
I even like dark world it's got some
moments it's got moments but this is
just like holy [ __ ] if you were doing
this every time if you were doing a
[ __ ] version of the Flash Gordon
[ __ ] movie every time we would have
been on board the big bad way yeah and
I'm here from Valkyrie all day every day
yeah hell yes that was such a visually
stunning sequence yeah her attacking out
all the great flying knives and [ __ ]
dying Jesus fantastic number six Wonder
Woman yeah [ __ ] that was this year
that was this summer that was this
summer yeah that make my list as well
the the back half of that falls apart
for me a little bit when it turns into
when she fights Ares yeah her world
whirling garbage in the sky fires
everywhere but I still went with it
because it was Ares I was like oh my god
he's in the comics like my bar is very
[ __ ] low so that did make me happy
like that they didn't make up some
[ __ ] dude that it actually has like
fun
Wonder Woman DC Comics or yeah so yeah I
was I was I was okay with that more than
you were I think yeah but I think that
the no man's land sequence in the middle
Fenton still may be the most triumphant
thing I've seen on the screen this year
yeah and also defines super heroism yes
cinema like it right it's it's a movie
that I'm DC movie that finally knows
what these DC characters are supposed to
be and when they're supposed to be about
and so I'm here for the no man's land
I'm here with a mascara I'm I'm here for
the mic to get in your mouth I am less
here for the other [ __ ]
number five Coco alright so Vaughn yes
we to five go back ten through six okay
ten war for the plan of the Apes nine
guardians to eight
spider-man homecoming seven thought
Ragnarok and six Wonder Woman very genre
have been in your back I went I went big
genre alright John here we go top five
number five
Coco okay Coco or the new Pixar
jammy-jam which is a beautiful movie
about the the desire to make art the
desire to not compromise in your making
of art oh sure of family and their role
in supporting you and your dreams now it
makes sense my daughter came home from
Coco she's like you're gonna cry like a
[ __ ] and I said really and she goes
every [ __ ] theme is for you you gotta
go better than Earth it is it is very
much about you know not being forced to
choose between the thing you love and
the people you love
oh my god and it's it is so culturally
specific in a way that's that's really
heartwarming like I am NOT of Mexican
descent but I can absolutely appreciate
in the same way that I appreciated the
no-man's land and what that means to
women who've been waiting for 75 years
to see one woman done well on screen I
can appreciate what it must be like to
come from a Mexican family and to have
these pressures and to hear these words
pronounced this way to see these
signposts of cultural specificity to see
the land of the dead these little Martha
done as rich and as textural as this is
it's a beautiful achievement that's
Universal through with specificity in
spite of it beautifully put
quick question did you see guillermo x'
day in the dead movie i did
book of life yes I mean I'm not saying
what are the what's weights they share
some tonal similarities they share do
they both also go into the land oh they
both go into the into the land of the
dead there are different movies to be
sure lately but but yeah it's one of
those like oh we both made a World War 2
movie so there's soldiers and guns but
they're different movies kind of the way
like Pixar DreamWorks for like oh we
made bug's life no we made ants go
figure right huh yeah what a coincidence
bugs reason anime we don't know how to
do this yet here we go not the [ __ ]
reason yeah because people that's my
toys like a you know a Toy Story because
you can animate toys the surfaces are
plastic and shiny you don't need the
texture of skin you need to worry about
hair yeah it's super easy to do buzz
show Andy and then you're like a robot
alright five colossal notch oh yes
wonderful move nacho makes my little
dough with Anne Hathaway's Jason
Sudeikis Jason Sudeikis it's this sort
of weird beautiful movie about guilt and
responsibility and and being responsible
for your actions even if you think
you're a horrible person yes that also
involves kaiju and giant [ __ ] revenge
plots and crushing of cities but it's a
sweet little story about a woman who
thinks that she does the wrong thing all
the time I'm with you 100%
I thought the movie was absolute magic
when I saw it and couldn't wait to share
it with people like oh my god I got to
show you [ __ ] this flick yeah
incredibly original even literally never
seen the story done before no and you
can't even be like I saw no it's not
really truly original if you're looking
for something when you go to movies if
you're looking for something that's not
familiar you ache for something like
just show me something new this movie
showed me something new in a way where I
was like I never put these two things
together yes clever as [ __ ] and deep as
[ __ ] yes for sure good call excellent
point number three in the shape of water
I haven't seen it yet really yeah I
almost wash it last night I watched
Molly's game instead yeah
how is it it's it's lovely it is there
it's like lyrical romance trailers
beautiful it's it's it's Guillermo de
Toro who lives in this world of magical
realism who decides he wants his own
story about this mute woman who falls in
love with a Creature from the Black
Lagoon and he makes the textural he
makes the magical realism feel real he
makes you buy that romance he makes you
buy why those characters want to have a
romance Michael Shannon is fantastic is
the sort of government spook who's
trying to dissect the the monster then
you have a name for him really and Sally
Hawkins is phenomenal as this young
woman and it's a movie that's about it
takes place in the 50s so it's about
people who have been subjugated in one
form or another it's about women who
don't have the sort of equal footing in
the workplace it's about racism it's
about sort of gay rights like Richard
Jenkins plays this lovely older man
who's just alone because there's no way
for him to be with anybody in this world
at this time it's a movie about people
trying to connect and who all kind of
levia themselves behind Sally Hawkins as
Lisa I think her name is who's just
she's found a thing to connect you which
just happens to be a creature from the
deep it's lovely and it's sexy as [ __ ]
like this is a movie that is all about
the embracing of feminine sexuality in a
way that is not stigmatizing it at all
that is that it's embracing that power
and that desire to be the fullest
version of yourself in every way it's
beautiful welcome aboard man that sounds
great
number two is get out oh right on yeah I
mean it's it's it's another original and
another original yeah I mean it's it's
it's hard to find a movie that spoke
more sort of loudly about where we are
right now it's a political work you know
all art is in a way political but this
is like staking it and [ __ ] staring
in the face but it's a thriller like
it's it's not hard but it's it's a movie
about tension and it's about Rosemary's
baby baby baby level tension yeah like
it is about intimacy and tension and
trust and betrayal and all that [ __ ]
buried in a genre movie that happens to
be a
something called the coagula and the
sunken place which [ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah yes and there's a bit of like you
know science fiction to the whole
[ __ ] thing but you don't really even
think about that element no no because
it's it's the texture of it is such that
you just buy it all yeah I'm gonna roll
with it oh man good Paul yeah
and number one another movie that came
out in February of last year Logan Wow
that's number one
Logan is my number one for you certainly
don't have to defend that but go ahead
but do it anyway I mean it's it's it's
it is this perfect it's the other Exodus
movie of the list in that it's about
it's the one last ride it's the last
[ __ ] cowboy just doing the one last
good thing of his life and it carries so
much weight to it because we've been
living with Hugh Jackman as Logan for so
long and we've watched him age we
watched him mature we've watched him
carry good movies and badly watched him
do great things and horrible things and
to watch this last great send-off for
this amazing actor doing an amazing role
in this character it just did it the the
elegy for Logan for me is what makes
that work and it ends exactly how that
movie should end it should end in
triumph and heartbreak and that's what
that does it's also a genre Buster of
sorts just like Deadpool the year before
it's like alright you know what a comic
book movie is let us show you what a
comic book movie could be if we go in
this direction it kind of bent people's
preconceived notions it was the one that
went R after Deadpool Deadpool you get
away with a fun R because a lot of humor
but they're like we're gonna go hard R
and the r is for the violence and it's
gonna be [ __ ] up and he's gonna curse
and even [ __ ] Professor X is gonna
curse and it [ __ ] worked on every
level it felt like you're reading comics
when we were kids you know Marvel had a
grown-up line of books called the epic
line of booms and it felt like oh [ __ ]
this is an epic version of an x-men
story it's big they feel like the
audience has grown up enough to handle
this and they were absolutely right and
that's still a [ __ ] risky movie to
make like I salute them that they
actually gave that [ __ ] a shot to a
person who deserves all the solutions
golde man he was let's make this [ __ ]
let's do it for the last hurrah oh my
god and he look I what was the other one
he did the Wolverine yeah like that
totally fine had the silver samurai on
it but this was like a quantum [ __ ]
leap forward man like given the tools to
like really go nuts where he's like let
me tell a [ __ ] great story don't
hamstring me by like I got to get a PG 3
pg-13 rating let me do something with
this character where he could pop claws
through people's [ __ ] skull let him
go savage and he'll pay the price he's
gonna die at the end of the movie
spoilers but let us not gonna do that
and they let him go for it man like both
him and the [ __ ] studio deserve hats
off to that yeah and there's there's
there's a strain in that movie that
reminded me when I saw the last Jedi
which is glass Jedi's about burning what
came before to make room for what's
gonna be new and half a [ __ ] Logan is
about like all this [ __ ] in your comic
books only about 25% of it happen and
none of it like this like it's it's it's
looking at itself and saying most of
this is [ __ ] none of this is real
this is what matters like you know one
last ride you know a father's love for
his daughter slash clone and an old
man's desire to go out on his own terms
great list give it up for marks list
everybody
[Applause]
wallet is fresh in my mind since we're
talking about Logan and Fox and the X
Universe the biggest news that happened
since we last had a show is what was
speculation and what was a dream for
some and a nightmare to others as you
pointed out as we assume some people are
gonna lose some [ __ ] jobs over this
and stuff but for those of us are just
like oh my god I wanted to see Fantastic
Four and the x-men and The Avengers all
in one movie it looks like it's gonna
happen that Disney Foxx thing turned out
to be real as raincoats and it's [ __ ]
going forward for how much fifty two
billion fifty six billion dollars in
cash and debt and it's not just now this
is the buyout is it a merger which is it
I think it's it's an assimilation I
think that Disney is taking Fox assets
but they won't it won't be Disney in
conjunction with 20th Century Fox Disney
just gonna own that [ __ ] I think so
yeah and so I think that they the
discover but I've heard is that they're
just gonna keep Fox in the same way that
they used to keep Miramax or touchstone
like Fox will be just an imprint oh you
think so I think so because they're also
keeping the lot like they're going
they're not selling the Fox a lot I
thought Fox is keeping the Fox look it
comes with a Disney deal Fox will lease
it from Disney but Disney's gonna be the
owner of it so they'll remain so just
like Marvel Studios exists exists at one
point Miramax was part of Disney's well
Hollywood Pictures touchstone Fox will
20th Century Fox will be a division I
think so so the Simpsons were right
there's that episode yes where they show
the Fox front gate and it says 20th
Century Fox the division of Walt Disney
yeah you know and there's also the world
in which all of the Star Wars movies can
have the Fox fanfare in front of it
because now they own Fox
so that doesn't have to be a Disney
Castle can be the 20th Century Fox I
just have a Disney castle at the
beginning of last Jedi it went straight
to Lucasfilm Lucasfilm yeah yeah I think
that's conscious they're like we want to
piss the fans off I think so I think so
but now you can have the [ __ ] fanfare
back
and that's something is weird it's like
you know now you get red M&Ms again and
you're like holy [ __ ] thank Christ as if
it mattered but it's nice to have
something familiar back yeah when is
that now they've said that like they
were making plans for this in the Marvel
movies already it's not like they're
like holy [ __ ] this just happened now
what do we do
like Kevin Feige apparently was
factoring this into future plans for
Marvel's phases right I'm sure they told
him yeah we're working with a lot more
characters to play well yeah how quickly
do you think they could do that do you
think we see any x-men or Fantastic Four
characters in infinity Wars I think
they're still in production um you could
you could whether or not they wanted to
bend that far backwards but if this is
the end of phase 4 right then phase 5
can absolutely be about the integration
of the rest of that [ __ ] if you think
about it if you were gonna lose a Tony
Stark or you know Steve Rogers and
infinity wars they can now be like yes
like they're gone but guess what
Reed Richards Azir [ __ ]
Professor X yo yes but Professor X is
there as much excitement because the
like we've seen professor X over and
over again and if they do it is it the
professor professor X of the current
x-men universe or is Kevin Feige get to
cast his own Professor X like do I have
to be scared one day it's like Professor
X is played by Bruce Willis or will it
be the the crown jewel of the entire X
universe is Logan and you have to recast
Logan so do they cuz he said he went on
the record at one point and he's like it
said like if they [ __ ] ever crossover
the x-men the Avengers I'll come back
and play Wolverine you don't I think he
said it but he'll be 63 years old by the
time that happens and he don't matter in
that [ __ ] movie Logan they showed a
bit like 25 again like when they did the
young version of them
so you can always see GM I think some
but I think I think you recast I think
you you soup-to-nuts it you like you
know what in this universe in this world
we need to do with spider-man yeah
plan for the future not the past so do
you think this next x-men movie is the
last go-round of that version of the
characters I think so I think so that
iterations so from there forward if they
enter the Disney movies were the Marvel
Studios movies it's completely different
magneto completely different I mean the
only the only reason to keep that is
Jennifer Lawrence you know right like if
she's if Logan is the crown prince then
she's the crown princess and you don't
want to get rid of her but still why not
start with a clean slate you can get any
actress at this point to play any one of
those roles any actor at this point to
play in that [ __ ] and and get paid
that way [ __ ] yeah
it's not just those characters that
Disney now has it's the Simpsons
it's EXFO avatar it's Planet of the Apes
quiet Apes as Disney really wants to
within the next 10 years they could be
like mega crossover with your entire
[ __ ] childhood they put it all it's
all their idea
do you think the government will okay
there's a SP okay there has to be okay
it's got to go through regulation and
antitrust proceedings and all that [ __ ]
let me put it this way do you think this
government will okay it
I really think somebody but like that
sounds like someone's having too good a
time [ __ ] shut it no more fun yeah no
fun zone I don't want to see the [ __ ]
x-men crossover of the Avengers [ __ ]
that say no to that deal yeah but and
there was also this figure that came out
that in the merger whatever takeover
between five and ten thousand jobs will
end up being eliminated which is a lot
of shows first you are for sure because
there's once you buy two companies like
that there's a bunch of overlap that you
don't need you don't need two
distribution arms you don't need to PR
arms you don't need I mean you need the
physical production you need development
but there's a bunch of [ __ ] you just
don't need two versions of and there's
gonna be a lot of people like looking
for work and now there's one less studio
to find it
you know we talked about but before
that's the sad truth of the deal man
yeah but it's happening it's happening
which like is something that you never
could have imagined that that cures all
the ails right like they're obviously
dealing well with Sony visa vie
spider-man mm-hmm the only characters
Marvel characters that were elsewhere
are pretty much the Fox stuff with the
x-men the mutants the only the only one
that is still the Hulk is it Universal
and I think but they could still they
can click it off they can include hope
but they can never have his own movie
can't do a hulk solo movie and I think
Namor is a universal also oh is that
right yeah I don't think he came with
the x-men or Fantastic Four for that
matter so really cuz oh that's a
predates fit no yeah he predates
Fantastic Four yeah
Wow so I think those are the two last
holdouts Wow
do you think they'll go after that as
well we're buying everything to complete
the set yeah just a bunch of nerds going
I got a bagging board everyone and [ __ ]
I got along that's awesome I can
identify with that meanwhile Warner Bros
is like we did it ears ago [ __ ] there
are other characters under one [ __ ]
umbrella we just don't know what to do
with them we got them all here we just
broke them all all right man so that's
all the news that's fit to print done
and done that's the end of that part of
the show ladies and gentlemen the next
part of the show is I think one of my
favorite parts of the show QA we open it
up to you guys in the audience and we
find out what you guys want to know and
we give out [ __ ] cool as prizes for
it man once again I can't blow these
people enough you ever see a movie in
40x ladies and gentlemen good folks at
40x have given us tickets to give away
if you've never seen a movie in 40 X
years what happens if it's snowing in
the movie it's snowing in the theater if
there's motorcycle screeching you're
smelling burnt rubber
for Star Wars when they do the crawl in
the beginning your chair goes back like
this and it's almost like you're
involved with the crawl it's wonderful
it's the next version of seeing a
[ __ ] movie
no stock in the company I just love what
I love and I saw two movies in this [ __ ]
and I was like this is the [ __ ]
future so they give us tickets to give
away and stuff if you haven't seen the
last Jedi audit or even if you have this
would be the way to see it for DX so
we've got 10 tickets which means five
fare we also have Q separate those yeah
tickets from our good friends across the
way at Ripley's Believe It or Not man
the museum goddamn Hollywood staple are
these broken up into to a pair to per
envelope beautiful thank you so the idea
is we're going to give you if you gas
cool enough question the tickets and
tickets you get to go see 40 X movie we
give you two because we don't assume
that you'll be like one please like you
want to be with somebody and [ __ ] like
that and if a person's like I get
nauseous watching movies in 40 actually
could be like well let's go to Ripley's
then all right here we go man who's
working the microphone what's your name
everyone give it up for Cosmo man he's
suffering for your sins he's gonna bring
you the mics wampa hat yes I am back so
with Disney's acquisition of acquisition
of Fox the Fox had already said that
they were willing to reboot Firefly if
Joss Whedon was down with it what do you
think is gonna happen now that Disney
owns that property are you you're you're
more of a we denied by a we denied I
still think that the financials behind
Firefly or rocky for more Firefly you
know and to be fair it got a [ __ ]
movie after being canceled after 13
episodes of a TV show that is life
beyond life that is hope beyond hope and
Josh seems to be in the Warner Brothers
camp at this point anyway do you think
he can go back and forth though do you
think like it's like hey man once you
leave you can never come back they won't
prodigal son that guy he literally gave
them their highest-grossing movies the
Avengers I mean granted Kevin Feige gave
us the Avengers
via joss whedon integrate castes and fun
[ __ ] like that and all the movies before
it but that being said it's like he's
the guy whose name is on the
highest-grossing Marvel Studios movie
there is do you think there's any
possible world where if not Marvel he's
welcome back at Disney like look at Jon
Favreau he built the Marvel Universe for
the [ __ ] Ironman and then after
Ironman too though like you're done and
he's [ __ ] gone but then he went to
Disney and start [ __ ] making huge
Disney movies now making Lion King so is
there a world where Whedon comes back
into the Disney fold if not the Marvel
thing it's possible but you know in the
press tour for Avengers age of Ultron
Joss had a somewhat public very public
falling-out with Marvel what did he what
happened there I know this but there was
there was there was lots of statements
on his part talking about the rigors of
working for Marvel talking about the
pressures that he was under talking
about the sort of lack of forgiving
quality of the studio in letting him do
what he needed to do with the amount of
time that he didn't have to make that
movie yeah he was not shy at all about
talking about the the machinery of
Marvel whether he's gone no chance
coming back I don't know I mean again he
made them like 5 billion dollars so it's
possible that look hey you want to do
your tiny little passion project thing
ok sure sure I think they'd be easier I
think if he was still at Marvel and they
wanted to make him happy do they know
that Firefly I didn't know that was part
of the deal I don't know if they know
they have Firefly
do they have Firefly they would it was
Fox did Fox but Universal Universal made
the movie right that's a good question
though man he wins some tickets give it
up for him ladies and gentlemen
we're going X Cosmo I would be more
excited about somebody making a really
great sequel to aliens ooh
cuz I haven't seen one that's true there
were seven other alien movies but and
now Disney owns the aliens as well yes
everything they had him in a theme park
ride remember at one point like MGM the
great movie ride that is seen from
aliens so I don't know that's a return
hey where we going oh hello hello how
are you I'm doing good I had a question
about the Fantastic Four since Fox and
Marv are now in bed do you think
Fantastic Four is better on film or in
television and I followed mark on
Instagram and I was wondering what that
meeting maybe you can explain there's an
Instagram where there's a mine you take
yeah I had a last week was the the week
of awesome hell for me where not only
did I catch a cold but I had like three
or four really huge meetings one of
which was a Marvel temperate [ __ ]
Barry that microphone in your mouth get
it right here man do you promise I'm
gonna right [ __ ] here ask you the
whole show like it's a vibrator and
you're like here we go right here right
here on the mouth just down the chin
yeah take it let's rest it there told
you I got a little dent do you do
Fantastic Four I mean I don't know man
like The Incredibles 2 is coming and The
Incredibles are still the best Fantastic
Four movie I think we'll ever gonna see
I don't know if we want more of that
what do you think
what if they gave Fantastic Four to Brad
Bird is it redundant I mean if I'm him
like I've already made the best one of
these laughs am I gonna make more of
these this is all I want to do is
families with stretchy things maybe
maybe see I don't know I mean you could
do TV you could do like you know no
ordinary family but just call them
Fantastic Four but you don't think
there's I pictured us they go movies
with them for sure
yeah I mean if I get that into a TV show
I think you just make them part of the
fabric of the Marvel Universe or more
than break them off into their own thing
I do a microphone if not they can't hear
Christmas gifts only [ __ ] what are they
man 3d printed ornaments I made for you
guys 24 hours ago
Oh [ __ ] a command thanks for all the
funny oh this rocks man thank you thank
you for man thank you
holy [ __ ] that's gorgeous you want a job
and I was forced to sign about a dozen
non-disclosure agreements when I walked
through Marvel but it was a good meeting
I will say that but I can't say why it
was a good meeting wait where I'm so
busy trying to get your mic in your
mouth what is this story where did you
go now to meet Marvel TV really yeah did
you meet with low no okay I don't rank
Loeb yet okay we'll see but now it was
it was a good meeting there are there
are possibilities you smoothly I'm gonna
plug you for details in the alley
afterwards sounds way dirtier than I
mammoth buddy ran your mouth talk you
for details
I know these are very aggressive
overtures right on man that's a great
question you in [ __ ] tickets plus you
give us an ornament give it up for me
once a ticket Slade's done thank you for
that
hi Cosmo where we're going next you guys
are gonna rock scissor paper for it well
done a little battle there I liked it
hey guys how are you oh hey hey yo I uh
I got a question it's Star Wars related
as part of the expanded universe so just
with the comics net if there was ever a
trilogy or a single movie you have to do
from somewhere in the series what would
what would you pick it on again that was
like just loud as [ __ ] so as part of the
expanded universe in star wars with the
comics and that there was ever a trilogy
or a movie you have to film base it off
so like you know Exar Kun or Knights of
the Old Republic well hold on hold on
so if if there is ever something that I
could base it on previously published
material ignites the old like the late
like the pot of the legend part of
anything of Star Wars published history
or whatever yes what would we choose yep
gotcha um what would you you got an
answer I do i all right [ __ ] it they're
never gonna hire me I I would do the the
fall of Jenna I would do I would do the
last stand of the the Warriors defending
the khyber mines against whoever's
attacking the Kyra mines but the idea of
people who believe in the force
desperately but don't have access to it
who are willing to lay their lives on
the line to protect it I think there's
something incredibly noble about that I
think that that's that's a Bridge on the
River Kwai kind of movie that is a we're
trying a thing we're not gonna lose in
the process but we believe enough in
this thing to sacrifice ourselves for it
like I think there's there's a great
story to be told there that they hinted
at or ever so gently in in rogue one
I haven't read enough of the EU stuff to
know if they dive deeper into that
anywhere else but I'm I'm kind of
fascinated by that when I was kid they
started the extended universe with a
book called splinter of the mind's eye
that was what came out in published for
him between Star Wars and Empire Strikes
Back and we were all young and stupid
and there was no internet
tell us otherwise and so we all assumed
that's the [ __ ] sequels star wars man
it's gonna be like this and on the cover
it had Luke and Leia and [ __ ] Bader
and the in the background and [ __ ] I
always remember that fondly but I
remember trying to read that book and
being like this is inscrutable like I
can't I don't understand what's going on
I need this movie to be shown to me I
don't want to read The Adventures of
Luke Skywalker so I can't say that I
ever went deep on extended universe
enough to be like ooh we should do this
but is there an incarnation that I've
seen where I'm like that'd be kind of
bad as to do I mean look I think what
they're doing with the cartoons now with
like rebels is pretty amazing and if you
brought those characters into the
universe that counts as an adaptation
and who's that guy Dave Filoni Jesus man
that dude knows more about [ __ ] Star
Wars honestly at this point then
probably George Lucas and he's a dude
that sat me down where I was like
[ __ ] prequels man he goes here's
where you're wrong and gave me an
eloquent [ __ ] defense of even
midi-chlorians where I was like you sold
me man if this dude was like now eat my
dick I would have been like done because
your smartest man I ever met and stuff
so that guy I even told him when I
interviewed him I was like you should be
doing one of the [ __ ] live-action
movies and stuff and he was like look
that'd be fun but like here I get to do
what I want I get to tell this ever
ongoing story which they're wrapping up
now I guess and it fits into the Star
Wars universe and he was a guy that he
still is guy that turns to George Lucas
to be like what about this but it but he
still gets pointers from the guy who
created all this never forget there was
somebody else who started all this and a
guy with a bunch of ideas enough where
he's like I'm gonna make nine movies one
day you know and didn't do now online
but they're gonna make [ __ ] 96 movies
when all is said and done out of a
simple an idea that he built a world
that he created out of the notion of
like oh the hero you know this is how
our heroes discovered in Kimbella and
[ __ ] literature's the floor so yeah
that's what I would go for it let those
cats take it into live-action what's her
name the character the Jedi who is
friends with Anakin
ahsoka yes so kitano to see ahsoka would
be pretty dope and stuff there was a
moment where in the prequels you'd look
like badness oka like character but it
wasn't full ahsoka yeah so that's what
I'd go with well done man you get the
[ __ ] tickets give it up for him lady
Jung meanwhile where are we going next
cause right here like well hey kept
following following on your earlier
thing that JJ you'll [ __ ] JJ I mean that
was what I don't know I mean that there
that I walked out of the theater think
of the same thing my god he is [ __ ] we
in the future I was thinking about past
JJ
well I was but episode 3 yes they come
to you they say how do you start it this
one the next one I'm sorry in episode 9
oh man you're asking the wrong guy I'm
like alright how do we start it with a
lot of words in space yeah but look you
got the job [ __ ] I'm like yeah
now what
Princess Leia died in her sleep that's
that is honestly it's a big problem how
do you solve that man like and they've
already gone on record saying we're not
going to digitally recreate her we're
not going to use footage and trick the
audience so yeah it's a tough hand to
play right there I don't I don't man I
don't know I'm not creative enough see
that's why you never see me going like
they should let me make one of these I
couldn't never [ __ ] do it like all
these ideas are wonderful and out of the
realm of possibility for even my
imagination i sat there watching last
Jedi go I would never thought of that I
would have never thought of that like
those are cool things I like being able
to be a fan but how would this fan start
the [ __ ] next one which is supposed
to be the last one but let's be honest
is the one before they do 20 others and
you've got to solve the Leia problem and
Luke is not an option anymore they kill
that bar in the most ignominious way to
like he got blown out you know and at
one point there's like even Akbar is
dead I'm like what that's my childhood
man
but yeah he went away as turns out it
was a trap
death is a trial I don't know what I
would start with mark you try I did
Princess Leia died in their sleep in the
beginning of the [ __ ] scroll
surrounded by loved ones and friends
yeah foxy I'm not creative enough I
don't got it you know my [ __ ] go-to
answer is oh no Boba Fett to make me
happy I guess but like what does have to
do with that him hang him like nothing
man but look at him beautiful oh my god
he ain't in some Sarlacc pit he's alive
[ __ ]
that's who [ __ ] what's his [ __ ] could
have been man Snoke imagine that if they
were like he's like I crawled out of the
[ __ ] Sarlacc pit and you're like holy
[ __ ] it's Ben Boba Fett all this time
didn't matter what with that yeah hey
did die in a Boba Fett fashion Boba Fett
crawled through eight miles of [ __ ] to
the gun out of Shawshank Prison he's the
Andy Dufresne of that you all right Wow
wait did we answer a question we're
going to another one no we were here yet
and we answered it you win tickets well
done give it up for him ladies and
gentlemen Cosmo who you got
find me a lady alright yeah we got one
since not alone I'm not a lady but
alright here we go we got tickets so now
that the years almost over and we're
almost in 2018 what TV shows our movies
are you looking forward to the most
coming up in 2018 what am I looking
forward to TV movie wise okay so last
yet I have it that's great she gets
tickets pass these back please give it
up for our ladies and gentlemen what I
mean yeah that's the the notion I guess
is what am I looking forward to seeing
in movies or TV but honestly it's like
what is keeping me alive you mean like
what's giving me hope going I just have
to live to that next step of course is
Black Panther infinity war like as me
holding my [ __ ] breath
I mean honestly the things I look
forward to the most tend to be
ridiculous
big comic book movies I think that has
to do everything with the fact that I'm
beyond [ __ ] middle-age and of course
the older you get the more you just want
to reach back and I lived long enough to
a time where they're taking the [ __ ]
that I loved as a kid and putting it up
on the screen so I get to enjoy it all
over again on a completely different
canvas so I'm drawn to that stuff
naturally but there's got to be other
stuff out there that I want to see what
about you I'm waiting for wrinkle and
time
cannot wait black panther Incredibles -
Incredibles - excellent Pole yes a
little show called Castle Rock I can't
wait to see I I know a little bit about
a little bit they haven't even set a
date yet but I'll tell you when I know
I'll tell y'all first but you know like
Westworld - I want to see the first one
I both liked and loathe at the same time
so we're not gonna get to see Game of
Thrones all of this year right doesn't
get back to 2019 2019 what was a big
little lies actually it was a surprise
for me they said they're gonna sequel
eyes that I look forward to that as well
Jessica Jones - is coming in girona
that's really strong I think we're gonna
get a Luke Cage - at some point this
year the Marvel is in a cycle of
everything is coming back even the one I
wish wouldn't come back which I can't
talk about because I had a meeting at
Marvel shut your piehole next time you
want to be critical put your iron fist
in your mouth next to the microphone
what else anything I don't know man I'm
a little uh a little shy on movies deep
in the year that don't have a Marvel
logo in front of them
I know oh my god isn't that weird now
I'm living from Marvel movies a Marvel
movie and now we can add star wars movie
to star wars yeah I want to see solo I
want to see how that experiment in the
hand-waving editorial comes out did you
see the trailer for Robert Rodriguez's
new movie oh yeah Elita battle angel yes
yeah thoughts it's weird man like the
weird aspect is that they gave her anime
the weird ass giant eyes like but it's
also not Japanese but has the Japanese
eyes like I that's a weird decision to
make
I love Rodriguez I love I love James
Cameron James Cameron yeah my god I have
no issue no question that it's gonna be
beautiful to look at and the action will
be amazing but it's always that weird
like guys one of the other pick one but
you can't have it every way you want it
let's flip the question back what or
what do you want to see what are we not
thinking of ready player one excellent
[ __ ] poll I do really look forward to
that the last trailer they put out was
magical absolutely magical I mean you
know we know the book so we know what to
expect but he's he's taking it in a
direction where I'm gonna reading that
being like yeah he can't [ __ ] this is
on the page you can't do this in a movie
and he literally he's [ __ ] broad so
like who else has the juice to be like
I'm gonna [ __ ] put the Iron Giant and
the [ __ ] DeLorean in the same movie
and chill except Spielberg I'm telling
you that dudes coming back in a big bad
way not like he ever went anywhere but
he's coming back to the [ __ ] to the
VP's like I've laid the track of this
[ __ ] thing man like you think Marvel
movies are special the ready player dick
like look at it's all you I can't wait
to watch them no think they ever make
md5 do you think you think Spielberg and
Harrison Ford ever get back on a pony
but agent agent Pony if they do it's
just cuz he's like I just don't want the
last one to be the one that people
didn't like like if they do it's just
like maybe we could correct for Crystal
Skull and that's it they obviously
neither of them have anything to [ __ ]
prove that or if Harrison Ford was like
I just want a hundred more million
dollars
you know they're like we're doing it in
d5 is alive but it could be I could see
that happening I mean I just I don't
want it man like because my Indiana
Jones is not 78 years old which is how
old Harrison Ford will be if they
started production like tomorrow Wow
like that's a dude who can't run and
jump anymore really I mean and Indiana
Jones needs to run and jump he needs to
hang under trucks he used to [ __ ]
ride horses and not worry about breaking
a hip he's actually now older than his
dad was in Last Crusade his dad's dad
was who's gonna save you junior not
anymore
all right all right do you have any
suggestions that we're not thinking or
no you blanket as well no I I'm looking
forward to wrinkle in time wrinkles too
I think with the two Maze Runner is that
what you said from the back yeah Maze
Runner they they finished that movie
well what was what's-his-name from Dylan
O'Brien Dylan O'Brien got hurt when they
were making it and that for a long time
they were like they're never gonna
finish that [ __ ] movie it's
impossible and I saw trailer for it I'm
like oh [ __ ] they went back and finished
it including the scene where I think he
had the accident they show him jumping
from the train to the vehicle or vice
versa and I think that's where he got
hurt but they finished that [ __ ]
movie are you fan of those flicks or the
books you are don't be ashamed that's
fine
it's nice to hear somebody love in the
room man genre it counts I want to see
uh I think it's red Sparrow is that it
oh the black black widow move basically
yeah the Black Widow movie for long
Marvel never wanted to make it's like
[ __ ] it we'll do it yeah really we got
this is that this year for sure yeah I'm
definitely in the in the back for solo
for sure
here's my thought about solo though hold
on hold that thought will jump to that
here's an I thought about solo so what
we know about solo was you know the the
give-and-take that we got was his
[ __ ] movies too funny fire those
[ __ ] dudes and get the unfunny Ron
Howard quick and then they you know
repaired the funny movie i sat down to
watch the last Jedi and the opening
[ __ ] the scene is a bit it stick
where he's just like I'm holding for
Huck's please right because because
there's there's operator phone etiquette
into the distant past and I'm not
bitching but there was a lot of humor in
that movie so if if that was okay to
keep the Star Wars brand on and nobody
got fired like what were they
what are you doing pie in the face jokes
in that [ __ ] Han Solo movie I like
how do you get fired because there are
plenty of jokes in that way and I liked
it I wasn't like this feels wrong I was
like that's righteousness I think Star
Wars is about dad jokes and if anybody
is a [ __ ] dead jokey estab dad jokers
it's Ron [ __ ] Howard we want your
young edgy hip humor we want like Opie
human give us that [ __ ] you gave us with
Parenthood right on all right wait what
were you saying which one
cuz of Corinne I do I do look forward to
seeing I saw the trailer for it it is
also John boyega yeah yeah I saw him on
the posters like oh holy [ __ ] when I
went to see last jet I was playing
working in just elbas Sun slash and
nephew staff whatever black or Pentecost
maybe right did anybody see a trailer
for bright on Netflix does it look
really good
yeah that's coming what very soon let's
come and get Friday and now this is
Netflix making a giant max landis script
with David Ayer directing and Will Smith
and Will Smith the Big Willie style and
who's the other guy oh the joel edgerton
the guy that did the gift I almost went
Josh Hutcherson which is like this
shorter version of joel edgerton Pete
was a Peter what is the idea it looked
kind of looks like alien nation though
it's like alien nation but somebody
smuggles in a magic wand into this
particular version of reality which
apparently is like a right so like if a
magic wand is like a nuclear weapon that
also grants wishes I think is the idea
[ __ ] that yeah so right on I mean
it's Netflix so I don't have to leave
yeah I mean I'm on board all right I'll
look forward to that I've been seeing
like do outdoor advertising which I
thought was kind of yeah like they're
going hard on this yeah like I was
watching some sporting events over the
weekend and the commercials for a
Netflix movie during a sporting event on
network television on network television
and that's expensive airtime
I'd like the mic go right to play or to
easy
what anyone else got any ideas for
what's coming that's it hold on one sec
say get here it's a star face remake oh
yeah go Luna is in the Scarface remake
who is who is directing everybody now uh
it was supposed to be fuqua but he
dropped out so is it so coming in 2018
that's what they say like late 2018 but
remake some people were like what the
[ __ ] it's sacrilege I'm like they remade
it once like the one I saw was a remake
yeah but I
see where they go that's difficult we
forgot Aquaman is that definitely coming
on board for that movie I liked Aquaman
the Justice League a bunch like as long
as they get rid of the [ __ ] talked
bubbles and [ __ ] I can't wait to see
what they have planned so yeah the
Aquaman I look forward to dig it
what about over there oh [ __ ] we're at
it we're at it we don't have any tickets
you can ask a question but I'll give you
it you know what I can give you a bag of
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] pop chips car look at
that baryon brand for life repairman I
did I never like to have an empty bag
pop chicks pop chips galaxy puffs man
little bb-8 sand and Tie Fighters to
chill like that you can if your question
is good enough these pop chips shall be
yours get popped here we go try to get a
job as a spokesperson get popped here we
go did you read the original Ender's
Game books the there's about 16 books in
the series the one they made they made a
movie movie with Harrison Ford and I
didn't like it no it was not realistic
to the books but I was just curious if
you guys had read the books and if you
would like to see a more realistic
telling of the series you know in I
tried I didn't read it
nor did I see the movie but like I'm all
for like make the best possible movie
version of that book if you can but I
wasn't I didn't I can't even say I
didn't go deep on that like I didn't
hear about it until that movie and then
when I heard about it it was like Oh
Harrison Ford's in it and then the next
thing I heard was like oh the guy who
wrote the book is kind of racist or
something like that and that's when I
kind of tuned out did you were you in
Ender's Game I was a huge understand fan
oh really
I read all the books I read I read all
the books even the shitty ones where
it's not cool anymore and you're not in
battle school and it's just weird dudes
complaining about having killed
everything
I think the shadow boats like Endor
shadow and all of that stuff is kind of
cool that the bean cycle following that
character
but I don't know if you ever see anymore
that [ __ ] you know like they they took
their swing and they spent a boatload of
money and I got Harrison Ford and they
got that young asa butterfield kid and
it's not like it's a horrible movie it's
just not great it's fine the shadow
series would be a much better series to
follow it's got more depth yeah like it
it it doesn't follow your hero anymore
it follows another character and you're
just looking at the same events with a
different perspective I love those books
I dislike Orson Scott Card because he's
racist homophobe whatever it's both he
takes all the bucks yeah it turns out
that maybe sometimes you shouldn't ever
meet your heroes base no one can hear
you hey yeah the enemy's gate is down
all right man we still got now we got
popchips anyone else want to ask a
question for a bag of chips right over
here dude what you got you guys at the
table unclear pop chips go ahead this
bag of pop chips could be yours well
it's gonna be hers look it's a small bag
consolation prize this massive bag of
popped if scan absolutely be yours just
to follow up on that question and we
brought this up with ready player one I
just saw you saw disaster artist yeah
yeah I'm so I was wondering are there
any books out there that you would like
to see he turned into a film or a TV
show disaster artist is based on a book
written by the guy who was the act the
other guy in the movie the actor [ __ ]
oh hello mark the guy who played mark
yeah okay what is there a book out there
that I would like to see turn into a
movie
mm-hmm-hmm-hmm yes this is a cheap
answer but there's a book that I always
[ __ ] loved called flesh one wo n and
it tells the secret origin story of the
character that Chevy Chase played in the
movie and the books
well he didn't play him in the books but
in the movie Fletch so it Gregory
McDonald who was an author whose work
the Fletch series of books literally
taught me to write movie dialogue
because he wrote very light on
descriptive passages very heavy on
dialogue so it was just a series of
conversations his books were and
periodically he'd be like Fletch was
confused and then they'd go back into
conversation [ __ ] like that
so it was great training for a person
who grow up to write a lot of dialogue I
love the Fletcher the book I went and
read the book because I loved the movie
first then I discovered the work of
Gregor MacDonald through the movie that
Chevy Chase was in and stuff I even like
you know Fletch lives which was a kind
of poorer sequel but still I liked his
performance of the character but those
books were my heart I loved those
[ __ ] characters the world of Fletch
and I love the Fletch that was in the
books even more so than the one they did
in the movies so when they released like
Gregory McDonald did a bunch of them and
at the end of the series of books like
Fletch stopped working at the newspaper
he became a multi-millionaire he dealt
in the world of art and [ __ ] like that
and he it was far removed from what he
began as but Gregor McDonald was like
I'm yet I'll go tell an origin story and
he wrote a book called Fletch one which
is meant to be like Fletch one but it's
W ons the title cuz he wins at the end
spoilers and it tells the story of how
he first got his job on the paper so I
always loved that book I've read that
book I don't know 60 times over the
course of my lifetime I would love to
see in a movie I tried at one point I
almost made at a movie I wrote it as a
script and stuff I didn't really even
write it all I did was enter Gregory
MacDonald's book and then just break it
up by pages and [ __ ] because all that
dialogue is perfect you wouldn't want to
change it I would choose Fletch one go
OK two books one of them is a comic book
because I feel I should be on brand it's
a it's a book called strike force
moratorium holy [ __ ]
really yeah Wow order the new universe
that Marvel did and I want to say back
in the late 80s Early 90s yes but this
book was about an alien invasion bad
guys come to earth and the good guys
they're there their solution to the
problem of alien invaders was to
genetically enhance a wave of teenagers
by giving them sort of enhanced vision
and strength and all of that stuff so
they could take on the aliens the price
for that was their life span got
shortened to a thousand days so it was a
bunch of like really attractive
hot-headed pilots who are living with a
death curse and we're living with the
idea that that their power comes with
serious mortality I think there's
there's there's something really smart
there there's maybe really tragic and
there's a lot of pathos there tomorrow
it was New Year in the universe it was I
think the best of the new universe for
me
another book that I love nonfiction
called the black count and it is about
Alexandre Dumas the guy who wrote three
musketeers Count of Monte Cristo
his father was a general under
Napoleon's army was born on Haiti where
my father was born he was biracial in
the 70s at a time when for a brief
moment there was total racial parity in
France where no man on French land can
be a slave and so this guy was born of
an aristocrat and the slave rose to
become a general in Napoleon's army was
storming castles was leading brigades
was the greatest soldier that France had
ever seen for 10 years until Napoleon
had him locked up and threw away the key
and the tragedy and it's and it's it's
who The Count of Monte Cristo was based
on the dude's son who idolized his
father fictionalized some of his
accounts but was absolutely telling the
story about I was dad was locked away
for tens of years because Napoleon hated
him well and it's it's all true it's all
real it's all insane there's this
sequence where Alexandre pair
which is French her father has to climb
a sheer ice cliff to surprise a bunch of
Italian mercenaries so he does it with
two daggers in his arms climbing up
hundreds of feet
imagine a Juris Elba doing this right in
[ __ ] Napoleon they're [ __ ]
tricolour hat and everything climbs on
top steals a horse and kills 20 people
by himself and that's like the most
boring thing in this book I would watch
the [ __ ] out of that movie in a
heartbeat I think at some point cary
fukunaga had optioned the rights to it
because i think he wanted to do it as a
miniseries but somebody should make this
[ __ ] movie because it's it's all of
stirring her OSes and happening which is
now word I made it up heroism TM me but
it's all of this amazing stories of
derring-do and and honour and triumphs
and sadness and despair all in one look
what you got out of Mark you win a bag
of pop chips well that's all we got for
this week ladies gentlemen have you had
a good time I love doing this show
thanks to the good folks here at scum
and villainy for giving us home and
thanks to my good partner crime here or
the thinking half of this [ __ ] duo
mark barnard and give it up for him
ladies yeah we're not sure we might do
one more before the new year
yeah before the end of the year my to
show between Christmas and New Year's
will will let you know if that's the
case but if not this may be the last
show of the year for us here in this
space thank you for giving it's not like
I got a new lease in life on the show
but you know there's been a few
incarnations of fat man I'm Batman I
used to just be by myself in my house
talking to [ __ ] cool people that
worked on the characters and stuff and I
loved that incarnation the show I got to
dive deep into the minds and hearts of
people that worked on a character that I
absolutely loved then the show grew up
into something else where me and Mark
started talking about everything not
just Batman everything geek oriented and
whatnot and that was even more fun for
me and then we did the Youtube version
where we would stand on a stage first to
defy and then over my house and stuff
but when we came here and did it for the
first time everything about it was just
the right relationship being here in
this bar having a live audience being
able to give and [ __ ] say-so of all
the things that I wasn't expecting our
2017 and 2017 has been like a weird year
and terrifying for a lot of us and stuff
we didn't know what was gonna happen and
looks like we're all gonna make it out
of here alive unless north korea starts
bombing us all of a sudden [ __ ] like
that but in a world where everything
feels like it could have been real bad
throughout 2017 i-n 2017 feeling like
something really good happened we
started doing Fatman on Batman it's
coming villainy and it just [ __ ]
clicked you guys made me fall in love
with the show all over again so I thank
you for that the bottom I thank you all
for being here that is fat man
Batman for this week man to knit how do
we get in the show oh it's pretty good
same about times that's right that's all
we got for y'all fat man Batman this
week man I'm Kevin Smith
I'm Marc Bernard that's it I forgot our
names tune in next time
same bat-time same bat-channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
good night everybody the force be with
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]